this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised jumbo jumbo a very warm welcome
to our sunset drive from the Mara
triangle my name is David and in little
cameras boom boom good afternoon sir and
we have said fast to show you the
beautiful view of the Mara triangle I'm
at one of the highest point of the Mara
and I'm sure all of you knew the
elevation of the Mara is about 5,000
feet or 2,000 meters or plus and that's
the elevations a lot higher than Juma
and just look at that beauty of the Mara
triangle now if you carefully we have
lots of open spaces and in the midst of
this huge open space that we call
savanna we go to the forest
we've got smaller patches of green areas
and we got scattered trees that is what
we call the Mara savanna now not sure
you can see on the screen is a pretty
pretty warm day here and we are talking
of 33 degrees about 32 degrees and 91
degrees Fahrenheit 33 degrees Celsius
and 91 degrees Fahrenheit and that is a
very very hot for our standards here in
the Mara but that does not detail from
going down there and getting as many
animals as possible most important
ladies and gentlemen don't forget we'll
always request you to send us any
comments you may have any questions keep
us busy
hashtag Safari live as you show on
Twitter and that will keep us and you
engaged throughout the three hour also
period of the drive well ladies and
gentlemen and the only one in Kenya
today but down in South Africa whether
the gentleman would like to say hello to
all of you
indeed you are down with us here in
South Africa and it's a beautiful
afternoon it's not too hot it's a little
bit kind of partly cloudy and perfect
conditions for our afternoon game dries
so hopefully it's going to be a very
good Drive and we hopefully are going to
see a lot this afternoon because I've
had a few quiet drives and I think today
is the day that we changed things around
what do you think Sebastian exactly and
that's a clue as to who I'm with this
afternoon is that Sebastian is on
Cameron for those of you don't know who
I am my name is Justin like David
mentioned now it's been quiet the last
couple of days from many perspectives
actually it seems like the Ailey's have
kind of dissipates it a little bit not
nearly as many of them or so not too
many of our lipids have been seen and in
the last few days and so I'm hoping that
after kind of two days of fairly dry
when we're having it too much rain that
maybe we'll start to see some signs of
them this afternoon coming out so that's
going to be kind of good and for all of
you as much as you know seeing animals
as entertaining with of all the most
special sighting of them all is this
afternoon in the form of a very special
member of our team is back on the
driver's seat so I'm sure everyone's
going to be super excited to see that
individual rather than even the animals
at this stage but hopefully we'll have
some animals to show all of you I also
just bumped into Byron for those of you
who want to want to know how Byron is
doing he came to visit us quickly and
she said that I must say hello to all of
you and he's very well and he's actually
busy guarding some guests at under lazy
at the moment so came to say hello good
now are saying we have a special person
on the driver seats who's back and I'm
sure many of you want to see his face
and not my ugly mug so without further
ado let's send you across to mr. Henry
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this Sunday afternoon sunset Safari I
have Corson the third person to say that
to you but I nevertheless mean it as
much as my other two colleagues hello
I'm back from leave that's my name
God excellent and it's lovely to be back
in the hot seat and lovely to be back in
the bush those were two Egyptian geese
that I showed you earlier which of
course was very nice of me to do wasn't
it actually it wasn't me it was of
course Craig who is on camera hello
Craig have you shown us your fast thumb
could you do that thank you very much
it was Craig's fast them and we're also
going to show you if you couldn't
believe our beneficence is some Impala
now they are thinking about having a
drink talk to us of course there's
always using the hashtag safar live on
Twitter otherwise you can use the chat
stream on YouTube and we will do our
level best to find you something worth
looking at during the course of the
afternoon it's great I must say to be
back on Drive with Tristan and David
very nice to be driving with them
apparently some of you are overjoyed to
have me back which means that you
obviously overindulged heavily on your
Sunday lunch which I thoroughly
recommend so well done to all of you I
planned this afternoon as to head off
towards at in Ghana
now of course I'd actually don't know
where he is but we had some alarm
calling around for those Hooke damn the
staff this morning and so we'll go over
there and see if we can't pick him up
lying in the shade or next to the water
and perhaps investigating one or two
things
now I must just tell you that this is my
very favorite time of the year in this
particular part of the world I probably
say that a few times during the year but
this this is the one I'm always reminded
of most and that's because the edge of
the summer has kind of fallen off so
it's cooler there's not quite as so much
rain which of course is normally fairly
and for
fortunate but it just makes for these
long warm Pleasant days without the
violent heat of the summer and it's just
a lovely time in the year to be out here
and in fact it's a lovely time of the
year to be anywhere in the country the
wind tends to stop blowing a little bit
on the coast and the weather's pretty
much stable for the next two months or
so very nice
anyway I'm hoping for a Sunday afternoon
of well if not great action greater
beauty Paul apparently you say I'm your
fearless leader well Paula I wasn't
aware that I was leading you but I'm
very pleased to be leading you I'm not
sure where I'm leading you hopefully not
astray here are the impalas having a
drink now interestingly of course we
have a dam here which is of course
supposed to store water and while it
looks like this quite a lot of water
here it really hasn't filled up to the
extent that it might have and that's
because we've had a lower than average
rainfall as has been norm for the last
three or four years now and so I suspect
that we're probably going to have
another fairly difficult dry season
comes September and October this year
much as we did last year and the year
before that but for now this water the
grass is tall and thick the spiders are
out there are lots of butterflies some
of the weavers are even having a second
go at breeding which is quite
interesting
so it's just a lovely time of the year
to be up here like there's some
butterflies just ahead of us craigers
and there's some grass stalks
just kind of over the top of the front
and left hand side there you see them
there's some African Jokers
and that's it you got him
African Joker's beautiful spitting on I
think that some parottas patents the
grass cat's tail might be asset arias to
be she isn't that lovely
all righty we're going to leave these
butterflies head off towards Beaver soak
water hole in the northeast corner of
the reserve while you go back to dahveed
in the Masai Mara yes Jim's a very warm
welcome and I hope you enjoyed your
holiday and now you're ready to get all
the little parts out of Juma that have
been hiding for the last few weeks
well not sure leopards and rafts are
elated when we look at their last names
I only took of Camilla poodles and come
else I'm talking about giraffes having
the shape of a camel and produce coming
from the leopard but we got massage
raffia and this is my very first animal
for this afternoon how are you madam I'm
guessing your account the way you look
at me or the way I'm looking at your
ossicones you definitely look like a
good-looking Maasai gal well hon I'm
sorry girl but I'm sorry Ralph cow and
we all know that giraffes browse us and
my guess is he's feeding on a cusper
bush people would at times confuse
drafts and call them browsers because
I've seen him bending like that and
reaching long tongues as you can see
there do you see that
she just spots some grass so what is she
speaking the Kasbah bush twigs and
leaves
she also picked some grass with him and
what she did there is to get the leaves
and the twigs of that particular bushes
eating and his putt the grass out look
at that and very good camera out there
by Bungay still pretty warm and we'll be
out the whole day Devin how are you
today and it's good to see I live in
giraffe while David always a pleasure to
hear your noise now David I see who are
you coming from
because my other friend oh my
like part had been having a giraffe that
is it has been dead for the last two
days I was like what is David talking
about where did you see and not living
giraffe true correct correct character
David thank you very much for that I
guess this one is surviving and not sure
how far the dead giraffe Pat had with
the winner pride but this tells you
David we got loads of giraffes in the
Mara triangle a lot of choice he got was
he he is a lot of grass a lot of red
oats grass but if you look carefully she
is not interested
Paula how are you today
and you wonder whether David has a shoe
count Bungay look at leave the camera
don't look at me the eyes because I want
to talk to Paula Paula jumbo and how are
you today
waiting for the right temperatures I'm
shaking my temperatures you doing over
90 degrees for a high turnout you are
whether you use the empiricist Impala or
use the metric system and over 30
degrees Celsius that's too hot but my
green suka always and always
I'll have it handy just in case the
temperature's goes down as they have
been before we finish the drive to serve
that's very good question and you're
asking whether giraffes can break the
ossicles
yes and especially the males as much as
we know the oskins that you see there is
kind of an extension growth from the
scar it's very invented it's very
difficult very difficult to break I said
yes unless when maybe they would have a
very huge fight and very big out a bump
or each other but it's normally very
difficult because they am bended to this
cow I like Sager
you know horns of buffaloes or of what
odd you know
buffaloes what else has another good
example maybe antelopes but the ones for
the giraffes
to extend is like an extension of the
growth of skull should you see a skull
of a giraffe without the skin you'll
notice that's ideally there's no joint
between the hace con and the skull I
would say it's more it's very very
difficult to see it broken what we've
seen in the mayors is to see them being
roughed up or being shot or you know
being flat at the very tips because of
the fights that they'll have you know
once in a while and definitely as much
as I looked on the belly of this
particular that's fitting here you know
looking also at the end of the ossicones
the females you can always tell they
have lost extensions of hair or fur on
top of the oskins
very good giraffe definitely you can
tell he looks a little big she has
really enjoyed that Bush and our imagine
their particular mirrors of vitamins she
is getting from that Bush well I'll move
on and my plans today is to look for
Lions that are different from my
favorite pride the sausage pride I hope
everybody will be happy with that
but in the meantime we'll go back to the
leopard whisperer and get an update
well hopefully David finds his lions and
hopefully those lions won't be naughty
and grab another giraffe because I think
that would be traumatic for many of you
by the sounds of things you're all happy
to see a giraffe that was alive and not
lying on its side being eaten by there
we know pride anyway not much has
changed on our side of things we still
just bumbling about ever so slowly
trying to kind of have a look at sort of
any of the pans just checking if there
isn't any sign of anything moving around
what we have found that was moving
around was Herbie and Jamie from this
morning so he's checking made tracks and
tracks for a female leopard that was
going up and down and Jamie said to me
she wasn't sure where they kind of went
she couldn't tell and neither could her
be and so we're just doing sort of loops
and just checking the little water
points in case said leopard has decided
to just lie up in some shade somewhere
close to a little wallow but so far
nothing that we can see and so what we
probably gonna do is we're gonna head
sort of more to the western side of the
reserve and we're gonna try and sort of
scratch around there lots of hyena
tracks around that's for sure and we're
gonna just kind of scratch and then
we'll come to these areas again a little
bit later and see if there's anything in
these mud wallows cuz for now the mud
wallows closest to where those tracks
are is no sign at all and I suspect that
it's four ton diamond
Tania's been so elusive of late but it's
been read tricky to actually kind of
find out she hasn't been lying at water
points or anything like that she's
obviously up to something
she seems to be kind of keeping herself
as hidden as possible and then just sort
of appearing here and there in small
sort of doses keeping the mystery around
her strong she's almost taken after her
sister's namesake and become a shadow
cat in many respects but I'm sure she'll
pop out at some point and you'll get a
nice sighting okay it's always nice when
we get long sightings of tandy because
of how difficult she can be to find
wild alien any news of lions
so no nots not here on Juma I believe I
think the in coomer's hold on I did get
an update I can't remember if it was
yesterday or today I'll tell you now
give me two seconds
just trying to see if it was today yes
at 7:45 I got an update that they are
Lions south of this location which is
inside London lazy and I think it was
the in corners that were there I'd they
didn't say which ones but knowing that
the Incas were in the West that thing
might be them or it could be the sticks
because that sticks also in for a long
walk to the West the other day they was
seen all the way down near Savannah in
the western sector so it could be either
one of those but nothing on Juma the
Torchwood's and the telemetry's have
both been seen on Torchwood and before
soaked respectively and so you know they
they are was around just everyone seems
to be avoiding this particular section
at the moment and the Avoca males also
in before sook and Mannion 8c they kind
of bouncing between there but mostly
being seen on their own or as - I
haven't heard of all threes being seen
together for quite some time and to be
honest so no real lion activity at this
stage but you never know you know we're
just starting to get out and just
starting to move about so maybe we'll
get lucky and we'll find some tracks
somewhere along the line right we're
gonna keep going when you're hitting off
towards tree also universe see what's
happening on that side in the meantime
they back up to David see how he's
getting on with his lionsearch yes
that's right Tristan and I decided to
leave the drafts and before went very
far I heard like some Ellie's trumpet
and asks Bungay what was that ever
engaged it can only be one animal and
must be an elephant ride one day and
boom day was right because I had not
seen it from a distance because the
grass is quite high and the road was a
bit low where we were and just look at
that beautiful God funny because the
first animals who deal in the giraffe
was a female and now I got a second
animal which is a Nellie and my guess is
she is a female how cool is this the
only thing that made me come close to
her is hottest for female I think she
got very long tasks in general mirrors
we have pretty heavy and you know larger
longer tasks and females but I'm trying
to imagine it's very difficult to age
huh but I'm thinking how the female
those tasks are quite long now unlike
the giraffe that was fitting on the
casbah bush or the leaves and the twigs
now this one is fitting both on smaller
plants as you can see in her mouth and
grass at the same time so if you look
what she watch the mouth now is a
combination of crowns grass and all of
them will just go through I like the
giraffe that we saw earlier that would
separate the grass and the plants that
you know she was speaking here anything
is going to her mouth now I got a
feeling you know Elly's got little
softer or other sensitive skin compared
to the giraffe because the about half a
kilometer apart from the giraffe that is
to be formed and it's Elly but you see
the giraffes do not have as large ears
as the elephants in terms of cooling off
but this one every few seconds she goes
thumb thumb open close close open
ideally to try to cool off because the
temporal ground there looks a bit
streaming not sure for what reason and
they are always a combination of
theories
excitement you know sometimes stress it
could be anything to see the flop there
bug a very good I agree with you that's
tomorrow Ellie's have been showing off I
would want to ask Lauren but any one day
any one driver they have come out and
not seen a minimum of 50 elephants and
they'll be shocked and two three days
ago I think you were discussing it as a
bunga bunga is the camera approaching me
this afternoon
and what we're saying is we're thinking
all the migration is in surrogates now
Serengeti is a National Park in Tanzania
and Elly's they don't get very you know
along very well with their will because
and of course they become they retain
them
so anyway agrees Bungay most likely 80%
of the Ellie's found between the Mara
triangle and the Serengeti National Park
could be here because either yesterday
or the day before we had an average of
300 elephants boom game 300 in four
groups one group we guess was about 70
elephants together hot keep flapping
that's the only way you're gonna keep
your temperatures down and they like how
tusks you know have crossed a little bit
we also see the same in males but more
in females and my guess is because males
will wander how I fight not schewe I
know what I'm talking about
but I've imagined because females do not
fight a lot
the the deformity the forma T of the
attacks will go in whatever direction
but maybe the ones for the male a little
bit adjustment because they keep either
fighting or poking trees you know once
in a while
Brenda good question and you asking how
do these alleys get the little holes in
the is there a number of reasons Brenda
issuing a squall of that one it could
either be genetic or too
when young maybe and you know elephants
are both browsers and grazers they'll be
out in the grass they'll be out bushes
in forest they might accidentally get in
a very shop is a phone huge Sun or a
broken stick and then maybe pierces
through the air and then maybe it
doesn't heal very well Brenda that is my
guess or if the hole is too big it is
and then an opening remains there
another theory maybe Brenda if they go
for each other you see how sharp the
tasks are that would happen these are
the African elephants and our thoughts
most of them would be under trees but I
think they're still coping and managing
in the heat of the Mara triangle but
then the muscles of your ears have to
keep flapping in and out as the
temperatures maybe the next one hour
will be cooling down fantastic
no giraffe or the one giraffe made me
happy these two gals of Elly's have made
me happy but it's time to remind James
that he's back on duty and I'm gonna
give him an assignment and make sure he
gets us King Ghana before the end of the
drive and good luck James Roddy well
here we are at weevils who caught a hole
Hey well we say fairly pea green
coloured body of water and we are
looking at a very interesting multi
class vertebrates gathering there on the
little island of a blacksmith Lapwing
from the class Aves Oh birds and -
Terrapins from the class Reptilia
repatha i seem to be getting on very
well indicating that animals very very
distantly related indeed can still be
friends us to see well done example to
us all
now we've come here of course in the
hopes of finding ting gar na na na na
now I'm looking under all the bushes and
in all the little patches of shade to
see if I might spot is right belly
resting I'm afraid as yet I have spotted
nothing this is not that surprising it
is very very thick at the moment making
it very difficult to spot anything at
all odds here and interestingly the
hippopotami Scuba Steve and his
girlfriend snorkel Sarah seemed to have
absconded now I suspect that Steve has
gone in search of Sarah because she
wasn't around this morning he was here
looking lonely and miserable he was a
fairly miserable mind but he looked even
more miserable today because he was on
his own so that's what's going on here
at befalls hook water hole what I would
like to do now is have a moment of them
ambient appreciation
you will just heard that there are in
fact some would include was one of them
a couple of ox pickers going
Tufts on those
rattling Stigler
Oxbow gasps
that's wise all rather peaceful place to
tea some tea what some butterflies there
you Craig well done oh yes another
African Joker look at that it's very
cool
castrato you say this is damn cam style
well yes possibly with a little bit more
speed given that the camera operator is
not sitting you know with a delayed
internet feed somewhere around the world
making it very difficult to operate
Nezumi in this case is Craig who's
actually live with me there are those
African Jokers you can see there
I think Bob they got the name Joker's
because they are in fact very amusing
they are known as the pranksters of the
butterfly world I actually have no idea
about how they got the name jerker
I'll see if I can find out for you but
I'm not really sure I suspect that
somebody will know believe it or not
normally if I don't know it one of you
does
now the trick is to find out is that a
spotted or an African Joker's difficult
to tell from here
I'm just reading quickly in my app
no it doesn't say here and so I can give
you its latin name biblia and Vitara
actual area antastic there he says
because they mimic at the butterfly's
possible that ridden orange orange and
black coloration is a possum mattock
indicating that they are toxic but
whether or not that is in fact the case
I'm not sure I really don't know where
they get their name from okay I cannot
find in Ghana over here so we are going
to press on forward and to see if we can
find him some ones
we could of course be lying centimeters
from us in the long grass given the
denseness of the bush and his propensity
to lie very flat in it in all but the
coolest of weather
all right Tristan same idea as I have I
think he's a checking out another
waterhole let's find out if there's an
animal living
we do ever say my ideas James well just
on the opposite side of the property at
this stage James is up in the north and
I'm down in the south and we're just
checking for two points in case there's
some ILI's around or lo and behold maybe
even a buffalo which would probably be
the first buffalo I've seen this year at
Juma but no sign of a buffalo in fact
there anything that is got a heartbeat
disease impalas who you I must say are
looking as good as one could ever
imagine an Impala to look at look how
much it's shining
it's amazing how bit of rain and some
growth of grass and vegetation can make
these guys look as healthy as they do
you know you kind of see them at the end
of the long winters in sort of November
they were looking rather ragged and not
very good and then you see them now and
you see them kind of healthy and fit in
the coat sort of shining in the Sun and
it's amazing kind of transformation that
takes place with these guys but you can
see by they relaxed demeanor at the
moment they really aren't too fussed by
being at turndown so I would imagine
that there's not too much around where
you've kind of been scanning all the
long grass areas and a little shady
spots in case but unless no sign of any
sort of predator for these guys what's
interesting though is watching them feed
obviously we know that that's impalas
are sort of mixed feeders in that
they'll browse and graze but I've been
intrigued to watch the impalas of late
mostly what they eating is actually not
grass so even when they bending down
like that they feeding off a lot of the
little forbs that are growing so small
little trees that are coming through and
little sort of annual plants that are
growing which is quite interesting you
find that they not nibbling too much on
the grass and I think they would have
nibbled on the grass when it was a bit
shorter but now that the grass is kind
of seeded and what a lot longer they
trying to eat all the little bits in
between while they can Oh making to eat
the grass that's quite low down to the
ground that hasn't quite popped up I
suppose we've had a bit of rain recently
so there'll be some new shoots that
they'll also go after but other than
that well very very quiet on the side of
the world it's
what's much going on really can't even
see our monitor lizard at turn dams let
alone any water birds which is quite
just quite sort of sad in many respects
Roberts what is my take on the electric
Safari vehicles um Romans you know
obviously whenever there is anything new
this is gonna be great debate about it I
mean I I like I like it from a few point
of views I think it's will be a great
tool in terms of finding animals your
ability to hear the natural wilderness
around you is is hugely increased which
means that you'll be able to hear alarm
calls you'll be able to hear bird calls
you'll be able to kind of pick up things
that you might not have picked up in a
noisier vehicle so that's one aspect of
it the other aspect i mean from a from a
filming point of view if we had to have
electric vehicles at wilder's it's it's
much better as there's almost no
vibration when the vehicle starts and
moves around and so for the cat mops it
would be a lot easier or so much quiet
so when we would be driving around and
we can talk to you guys and wouldn't
have to kind of be drowned out by these
diesel engines particularly in the Mara
dam that cause you are not too bad so
from that point of view be really nice
obviously it's meant to be a cleaner
resource or cleaner energy that we're
using in order to propel them around but
I just still wonder what the longevity
of those vehicles are what happens to
batteries and things like that once they
you know no longer charge correctly and
and we're so the reaction of animals I
mean we've obviously been seeing a few
kind of electric vehicles in our area
and approaching certain animals and it
seems as though some of the animals
almost get a fright that the vehicle
comes in now you must understand when we
approach something like a lion or a
leopard or an elephant that animal knows
we're coming from miles away and their
hearing is incredibly good so they hear
this little diesel engine or a petrol
engine coming from a long long long long
way away and they you know make this
decision to either to stay lying me or
they believe or whatever the case may be
with this electric vehicle it almost
seems like these animals are being
surprised by the fact
they don't hear anything in all of the
sudden there's this big object near them
and so I'm not sure how that's or
animals are gonna overcome that are they
gonna get used to it and they're gonna
eventually relax or is it going to be a
constant thing where they get surprised
and it makes them feel a little bit
uncomfortable so yeah I don't know how
and it's an interesting one I haven't
seen them around enough and I don't
think they've been around for long
enough to really make any proper
judgments on them so I'm neither for or
against at this stage can I be like that
can I be a fence sitter so I think I'm
gonna be a fence that's on this one for
now then did you say good point I which
point are you specifically referring to
I suppose the animals would be the one
that you're referring to at the end of
the day you know the thing is is you
want animals to be able to have the
decision to be able to to move
themselves and to be able to react and
have the ability to make that decision
and if they don't have that ability and
skill are they being surprised how long
until one of those animals is aggressive
towards that vehicle so never too late
they most definitely are powerful enough
for Frode I was chatting to Brent I saw
been to the last week this last week
what are we doin know what day we all
went Sunday no this week I saw brains on
Tuesday and I was chatting to him and he
actually test drive one recently and he
was telling me that he reckons it's got
more power than rusty which I don't
believe rust is the most powerful car in
the whole world just taking him now he
said to me that they are very powerful
and no problem with off-roading and you
said that's the car had more than enough
to go everywhere where he tried to take
it so that's good news and the range on
those particular ones that he tried is
about 200 kilometers which is a big
range that they have before it needs
charging and the amounts of charging
that needs to take place is obviously
dependent on how much you use
and she can charge anywhere from we need
to be charging away from an hour to some
seven hours but you said to me that
they're more than powerful enough I
think some of the other earlier models
had huge issues with range but yeah
honestly I'm not not too sure how I feel
about them at this stage anyway
good let's carry on let's we're gonna
jump into Marazzi go and check what's
happening and there gets say about the
Sun cuz a safe seems like he's hot
behind me here I mean halides you that's
I apparently sending you to either David
or James I have missed the name because
I was too busy talking about electric
vehicles but either way they'll get
their opinion and what they think of
electric cars well I would agree with
you sorry Tristan on that feel about
electric vehicles well number one
personally out say they are great and
his concern of electric vehicles to be
the same as mine but only challenge is
we have found out here in the bushes if
you have a technical issue it's very
easy to get help from another vehicle
from a friend or from any other person
but I'm saying with an electric vehicle
if you do not have as many as those
vehicles they're gonna be a challenge to
get out but I would say they'll be a
very ideal now the Mara
unlike juma it rains a lot and the salt
chemistry of these two places is very
different we get stuck a lot more here
than in Douma I mean I kept driving
through Jamaa and I do not even remember
either twisting or James or any of the
other gates having been stuck there
because of their different soils that we
get so I do not know how well an
electrical vehicle would perform in the
Mara that kind of anger out highly doubt
they would fit here anyway
we got a fast start try them in Douma
and they
they can spread out this way but I think
Maura needs more of mechanical vehicles
well you need to shift the gears back
and forth and vehicles that she'll use
diesel because when you're stuck and you
have nobody to come and give you a hand
you have to use all your energy and you
need a very strong vehicle I think an
electric vehicle needs smooth roads not
big load not going descending on high
heels and not very steep desert I mean
that's my take on electric vehicles
we'll see it's maybe we'll end up trying
them in Douma maybe before coming to the
power well I haven't seen anything else
since I saw the elephants the two girls
and I've decided to go today to the
marsh area and find out what could be
happening there in the matter we got so
many prides of lions very many very many
and every time I'm here and like
recently before I went home I was
dealing with the sausages throughout and
any other pride or collision of lions
would get in the way out just ignore
them
but in the monotron go having over
tempers of lions I feel also once in a
while I should look for the others just
say jumbo gem how are you doing and look
at the dynamics look at the changes that
we've had since I last saw them so
around who I am
we have two prides we got the mashed
prides and we also got another pride
that is called the mara river pride so
those are the two prides are the tailed
hawk to see and there's one that you
call a my river pride that you have
always thought they are very shy when it
comes to hunting mmm
they never have the confidence and the
talents we have always seen them having
made a very good strategy
this starts stalking and we think they
have put everything in place and they
gonna catch the prey but then
the hunter boots for no good reason
unlike say the sausages that I would say
a nine out of ten times once they like
focus and they make a decision to hunt
nine out of ten times they always
winning well let's see for the RV lucky
to see I love those and I think I must
have missed something
they are merry I'll be happy if you take
it again for me
how lovely this air it is
very very good so I'll be heading to the
marsh area but I think I had requested
Ally James to get as a spotted cat by
the name of King Ghana but he's trying
to look for some bugs in the air
well what we have been lucky with here
awesome
oil toss now wall chess of course don't
normally congregated in vast numbers and
unless they have spotted something dead
and well the hope is there spotted
something that is dead as a result of
being in contact with King Ghana's teeth
and claws alternatively some other
predator I'm pretty sure that that's
what's happened because there was much
alarm calling around here this morning
and there were no vultures this morning
which means that something has attracted
the attention of these anomalies or
birds here now while you look at them I
must just weigh in on the electrical
vehicle debate frankly I think it is the
way of the future and those naysayers
are similar to those people who thought
that the horse would never be replaced
by the internal combustion engine and I
say that because if you have ever been
in a sighting why me many of you have
been in sightings with those electric
vehicles there is no question that
although the technology is not quite
there yet in so much as the vehicles
can't travel very far yet so for example
they would be hopeless in the Mara right
now because they can't go far enough yet
I can own you about a hundred kilometres
I think at a time before they have to be
recharged which you might get away with
a short game drive and the Mara down to
the bottom of the hill bit of a turn
around towards basically the route that
David's doing today and then back up
again but you wouldn't get down to the
sausage tree pride and BAC certainly not
with any speed and you'd often find
yourself stuck at the bottom of the hill
before you got home but that is just a
function of the fact that the technology
is not quite there yet that is
definitely where we are going the days
of the great big v8 4.2 Land Cruiser and
it's unconscionably irritatingly loud
starter motor are hopefully numbered as
are the days of vehicles like the one
I'm sitting in
which although much quieter belch out
any number of foul-smelling fumes into
the air and there is no question in my
mind that as much as we do our level
best not to affect the animals here with
our vehicles there is no question that
we do affect their their movements with
a largely to do with the sound that we
make with these cars and often that's
the stick that we're breaking but the
ribbing of the engine makes a big
difference
so there's no doubt with me that this is
going to be the way that we go and that
everyone else goes once the technology's
there and kudos to those who are trying
at the moment ok we're going to snuffle
around here and see what these workers
are looking at while you go back to
david and the will themes chisel beaks
to ground hornbill
well that's not very good with look at
it James about combustion engines and
electric vehicles and I'm sure I will
see what the future will hold because
they say change is a fact of life well
from vultures to other bigger BOTS maybe
more less the same sensitive water so
little bigger but now this ones are on
the ground but there's something
interesting going on here we have what
we call the thousand ground handles and
he got the black-headed heron but look
in the Mideast and tell me what you see
the goods and other animals there some
other small carnivores and I'm wondering
what kind of a party they would be
having with his gun hundreds and the
herons my guess he's loose who are the
banded mongoose but now just look at
that initially I was wondering what
types of birds are this how these chicks
or ground hornbills are they chicks all
the herons or are they what what am I
talking about
I initially the drama cops or some kind
of you know I bounce in the grass but
looking at them carefully they were up
and down and were more than twenty and
there's no way I'm going to see so many
Hummer cops together or so many irises
together
or you know so many buds lot of
different species from the two that I
see there and just found out there were
mongoose of the monkeys he's one of the
of the special setting of heart now we
all know that the ground hornbills very
endangered at at the moment and looking
at the eye you see and listing they have
been listed as very vulnerable have been
losing their habitat now definitely the
moon goes are here because of food
there's no other reason for them to be
together but look at the relationship
between the Mongoose and hornbills and
there's a buffer in the background there
are Bungay yeah is it a buffalo there
that's so good have this one frame
Bungay of the southern Granholm bears
hair on the moon goose and the buffalo
it looks a bit at Fisher when you see
all that together and you can see
there's some kind of either swallows or
sift that have just passed through your
screen and disappeared and definitely
they'll be feeding on snails the ground
horn is basically and we know herons
will be feeding on invertebrates see
there Tommy over right that's juvenile
you ask a juvenile one and that one is
the one at the very back but Tom we know
males have very bright what was in huge
waters than females and the females
right at the base of the waters Tom they
got a team or bit of yellowish or
publish and I think that's could be one
of them and there's one major difference
between males and females now when they
are young they do not have very
developed what was that a bright red so
so always a bit duck now when one of the
reason why these birds
gets in quite vulnerable is because they
take so long to mature so it takes about
three years for the youngsters to be
thrown out of the group by the adults
and for that reason if they keep losing
their habitat I'm talking of for them to
hatch for them to breed they normally
prefer very huge trees look at the moon
goes there
this meant smear the meerkats so they'll
order to be up and down very quickly
look for the safety and realize this is
nothing to worry and then back to
feeding dr. fall you say is a beautiful
view indeed I agree with your a percent
no doctor you know for a doctor here we
say that Terry Daktari look at that
green part there and this is part of the
marsh area of the Morrow triangle and
notice the difference or the killer did
the difference in terms of color of that
and the grass outside the marsh area
this is pristine and very dark green of
course because of the amount of water in
this particular area which I'd say
really dries around there we have always
said water is life change you asked him
as the meerkats in tomorrow and I would
say no we do not have meerkats tomorrow
and that's pretty good question our
equivalent of the meerkats in the Mara
would be the Mongoose or you just saw
there which I guess they are the banded
mongoose we just have the drafting goose
and we also have the marsh
Mongoose so we do not have mere cuts
here and I'm trying to think Jane you
need to move further down south to be
able to see them so the herons have very
good hunters so they keep moving and
even notice they are all moving in the
same direction for the Mongoose herons
and the hound wheels all of them go in
the same direction so I think the y'all
keep pushing their prey in the same
direction and they know exactly what to
be looking for either the mousse will
pick up all they want and leave what
they don't want for the birds
I'm trying to imagine this is the
feeding strategy here are the three
different species that are not related
in any way but very funny I haven't seen
this I would say this is the first time
I have seen
herons hornbills and minge monkeys
together fitting as always a first in
life and as a guide I did not rebuke a
have you seen this before don't get
doesn't think so
Suzanne this is black-headed heron and
that's a very good question the green
box here incisions are much smaller in
size they're much smaller in size and
apparently I'm just trying to open my
bag there than what I'm doing
apparently you get them in release
swampy areas or places that will hold
lots of water here you see is the
black-headed heron or the grey herons
but the black the green box herons a lot
smaller
very small this is a Bahama cop and we
see them differently
well trying to get to my herons here
Susan
hopefully you don't go very far and what
I want to show you is how a green box
Heron looks I'm sure you know
greenback's heron and the super number
trough Thank You Bungay for trying to
catch up with that one and that's the
youngster and you can see doesn't have
the red white or as the others look very
good
now I think Benguet it got a green box
Heron here for season so a little push
rod right there on the dashboard and if
you Susan is still there thank you very
much come give go to number six and then
thank you very much scientists honest of
that one there Susan is the green box
Heron looks little bit like a squawk OH
or a bitten but you can see very short
neck so that's the greenback Terran and
you can tell definitely let's shorten X
the juvenile doesn't have the Green the
6b or the one on top there that is
juvenile so of course the green as the
name suggests has a bit of green on it
and now let's see where they are gonna
see those heroes we have been talking
about now this is lovely
now look at number two Susan I hope you
still there this would have been
watching you the urban guy thank you
very much and that's what you called it
duck head of terror and look at the neck
of that one there
it's quite long compared to the green
box heron and you see really the black
curtain because black-headed it's all
black or them
and we'll look it's number four there
and before me if you go there you can
see that is the grey heron and doesn't
have the black as we have the
black-headed heron and I'm sure Mary I'd
be happy have you taken that question
again and of course the gray hair on one
made you have a difference they've a hum
have yellow beaks if you look at that
and sorry Bungay to move you up again
and that his black it's like the
difference of the animals but all these
bars would be feeding on now most of
these bars and most of the herons
in general will be feeding on
invertebrates and it's a wide spectrum
they'll be feeding on frogs any fish you
see that's one how she's moving they
move very slowly and very quickly you
see very and they're always very patient
any insects that they'll be able to
catch
they'll be also be feeding on it any
more asks that's they'll also be able to
catch
they'll also grab it but now the ground
Humber's get tougher things as I said
they would even be getting tortoises
snails
and for the tortoises they John Humvees
have got very strong and sharp beaks and
they'll always be able to break the
shell over turtles to feed on and this
is one exacting position of being no set
you've been for a very long time seeing
three different species of animals
feeling together well we'll move on and
one of the reasons I love this area of
the mush
is because because of its the greenness
there's always a lot happening it could
be any animal you could come it's not
along the whole sock will you take it
it's not more than ten kilometers but
you could spend a good two hours moving
and stopping every 5-10 minutes for a
beautiful sight in well hopefully the
governments in Africa now are working
very hard and what they're doing is to
try to sensitize the people and educate
them and you know either give them
alternatives for the big huge trees they
are cutting I'm talking about the ground
hornbills so that will keep protecting
these trees because as I said earlier
the gun hunters require huge trees and
they'll have the holes in those trees
and that's why they lay their eggs
otherwise if that works we are
guaranteed of having this gun hornbills
for many many years to come now I've
been talking of birds and but and I
think James won't talk of arachnids now
I'm alive oh hello everybody there I was
expecting a warning anyway here we are
at one of the very few golden orb web
spiders that we've had all year have no
doubt others have shown them to you this
is certainly my first one of the season
and I can remember a time in January and
February of course when you drive along
and you'd go off-road and the cameraman
basically would hide underneath the car
because of these things ending up on
their heads so what we have here is a
great collection of males and one female
can we see the female crow you're on the
female there she is glorious looking
creature utterly harmless to human
beings believe it or not they can give
you apparently a bite that might feel a
bit like a bee sting but really totally
harmless otherwise not so harmless to
the males they were often required to
give her a present before she will
engage in copulation and if she finds
their present distasteful she will turn
around and eat them that is why there
are quite a few of them here in a long
time since I actually read anything
about golden orb webs spiders but it's
very nice to have them here and for
those of you who are perhaps uninitiated
in the joys of the golden orb web spider
I'm not sure if you can tell how big it
is from where I'm standing but it's
about oh it's about two inches long from
a tip of the head to the end of the
abdomen and I suppose if you used all
the legs about the size of my palm so
that's about how big it is and like I
say harmless but interestingly they have
used this silk which is stronger than
steel believe it or not of the same
thickness they've used it or tried to
use it to make bulletproof vests and
that sort of thing because it's very
light and they've done so by
transplanting a gene from the spider
into a goat such that the goat produces
the silk from its udders
yes they are very amazing I don't know
how successful it's been because I've
certainly never seen a piece of clothing
but that has been described goats web
clothing you can imagine the branding
goats whip but that's what they've tried
because it is so very strong and it is
gorgeously colored in the slightest it
not it is really just amazing
now I've no doubt you've been told about
the clipped oh parasitic spiders and
that sort of thing but I've actually
spotted another spider that has got
nothing to do with this golden orb web
spider and here it is over here Craig
can you see where I'm pointing with my
stick newsy the tiny little thing yes
any about two millimeters long and it's
another orb web totally unrelated well I
mean it's a spider and it's part of the
family it's the same family is this
golden or web spider but it set itself
up on the golden orb webs supports
strands and I've not seen this before
I'm sure does happen but I've not seen
it before and it's used the support
strands for its own support stands and
it's got its own little orb web over
here and I have no doubt it catches
quite a lot and interestingly I don't
know can you see the wave at all the
wave is beautifully designed so all the
radiating spirals if you like are
equidistant from each other whereas if
you look at the golden orb webs web it's
one of the most untidy spider's webs
that you will find it looks like a sort
of I guess
derelict gypsy colony if you like it is
detritus all over the place
it looks like the you know the male's
clearly aren't doing anything to help
clear up she's got to do all the work
and basically she just let it all go and
so it's not nearly as symmetrical and
there's always muck about it and the web
is repaired rather than ream
aid which most a lot of the old web
spiders do very interesting okay we've
stopped in the area where our vultures
were we've done a little sort of drive
around off road to see if we can find
anything we haven't managed to come up
with anything just yet but there are
still vultures are on so I think we're
going to continue looking around here
I may have to go off on foot but we'll
just have another little drive through
here and see if we don't get lucky could
also be that these vultures are looking
at something the other side of this
little dry riverbed here the one that
feeds before soap dam but are not sure
they do seem very well of course right
hey Craig are you ready good good I'm
plugged back in Am I yes I I'm plugged
back in
so just knows through yep this is where
the vultures were looking
ah well Terfel you say used to hate bugs
until you were watching spoilers well
interestingly of course bugs are a
distinct order of insects but I think
you probably mean insects and spiders
and creepy crawlies in general and I
know what you mean because you know when
I started doing this job we'll started
guiding way back in the year 2000 which
seems like ancient history I was quite
distasteful well I didn't really you
know it's quite nervous of creepy
crawlies and things because I was from a
city out and really know much about them
and now of course they're a world of
fascination for me it's continuous down
here there's another vulture just up
there look there they are of course
white back to vultures Thank You Craig
they're all slow hit and they're
actually once you've sort of come into
an area like this it's not particularly
useful having a vulture because we know
there's something around here we don't
know where it is but of course that
vulture can see well pretty much 270
degrees without moving its head so where
the kill is from where it's sitting
right now it is almost impossible to
tell they also of course see a huge
distance which means that it could be
anywhere from right below it to I don't
know three or four hundred meters away
except for a quarter of a mile so even
though you do find vultures like this
it's often quite difficult to find what
they're looking at but try we shall try
we should I'll keep doing keep trying
shall us we it's now can be
Ryann vultures do not get sick after
eating dead animals for the same reason
that you do not get sick when you drink
milk for example unless you happen to be
lactose it have the enzymes that are
able to cope with all the fruit and
disgusting things that they eat many
animals don't have those enzymes of
course like us and were we to eat what
they do well then would probably get
very sick as well they also I think
probably like hyenas have extremely
acidic digestion which kills off many of
the bacteria and nasties that are on
rotting flesh rotting flesh being
something of speciality for the vulture
you know all species are resistant to a
certain suite of bacterium diseases and
pathogens and things that might affect
them and vultures of course having the
diet that they do must be very resistant
to rotting things otherwise they would
die
all right David Gothenburg ethu seems to
be having quite a lot of luck this
afternoon especially he's heading
towards the Marshall not surprised and
scale up and find all he's got
yes I think today things are going my
way in general have been seen oh the big
and moves us maybe James have been
talking small animals like the spiders
well the first animal was a draft it was
a female when I saw elephants also
females but now I found buffer was much
closer to us but they're not females but
boys outside in their own natural
jacuzzi and you can tell the one
flopping his ears just stood up and he
was in there not sure he wants to get
out of the jacuzzi it is getting a
little cool and the other one is just
there and shooing kada so what they do
after eating a lot for the better part
of the day just regarded and reach you
what they had swallowed a liya is I want
to call the dagger boys and to me I
think after the hippos this is the
second most dangerous animal in Africa
well because of the heat of the day as I
said earlier it was rather hot when it
started they'll definitely be there for
couple minutes just to cool off as much
as possible and once the things have
cooled off they'll just stand and come
out of that particular one oh now this
animal is not wanting chances with them
there too because the mouse but they've
been a whole group you see cows with
calves or anything 15 to a hundred
ravindra you're right the makeups they
have having different colors of inda
that's definitely the way you put it
I agree with you hundred percent and I'm
sure of winda you know how dangerous
what we call the dagger boys are
and not sure that you have heard of
people who ever had encounters with
buffalos and the stories they tell you
do not want to hear about them look at
them they will always look very simple
very harmless not knowing what's
happening around them but it takes them
seconds to make some big danger what was
the question from tuti what does that
woman see how they're looking at us they
look very mean and - do you want to know
something watch means OH - t sorry you
want to know what dagger means now I'll
tell you - - what Hawaii we give them
those nicknames dagger dagger boys
because buffalos have been known at
times even if they have killed someone
they tend to shred shred I mean they
tend to tear someone to pieces so and
you know how sharp daggers are and
people have used daggers to shred meat
or to cut meat so that's why we give
them those nicknames dagger boys dagger
just like a knife because they got very
pointed horns and those horns are very
sharp so even when you're dead they
still keep tearing you into pieces
that's how they got that nickname dagger
boys
all right dagger boys we're gonna leave
you there
what a view I've come out of the jacuzzi
we do not want to keep you out we're
still too hot maybe she may want to go
back to the water
ah haha I also learned something from
the director today and my director today
in the final control scott mhairi and he
has reminded me in zulu dargah also
means mud and that's quite a revelation
are to know have always said a
revelation and one of the technical
engineers in our camp here good Edwin
Lucy yes David us another revelation to
North so dargah I was known it could
also meet margin Zulu and they always
full of mud maybe both ways that's how
because that nickname dagger who knows
so I have a new way of explaining dagger
boys to all of you
all right need to move and gets to the
very center or to the very heart of the
marsh area and hopefully I'll be seeing
different animals I'll be more than
happy to see a huge heart of love I mean
elephants here with small little babies
because they never miss to come to the
marsh but also at the same time on the
other side of the mass in the forest we
have always chanced on rhinos and maybe
this could be the day
I haven't seen arena for quite some time
I've always been putting a lot of energy
and time on the sausage trip right and
I'm sure Mari in the final control will
be happy to see rhinos in Kenya we got
both black and white rhinos but mainly
here in Amara we only got the black ones
which are native to Kenya
the numbers are also coming up very well
but I also say out the moment more more
highly endangered than the John hallwas
that we were watching earlier I mean the
first different challenges at the Rhinos
have been facing challenges of poaching
unlike their grand in bills which have
been facing the challenge of loss of
habitats now the leopard whispered
Tristan and you please tell us something
well David I think it's not any for
rhinos but every kind of animal at the
moment is facing huge problems from loss
of habitats particularly as far as
forested animals more than anything else
you know the thing is with rhinos is
well white rhino and even black ran into
a degree they they can't survive in
these more kind of open clearing areas
and savannas but you think of rainforest
species like orangutangs and gorillas
and these kind of things they really
under the most pressure probably a man
or so you know a lot of the animals that
rely on water in many respects because
they unfortunately are being hard pushed
these days as the human population grows
now talking about water three sad
actually I'd you've been following
what's been going on in Mozambique so
for those of you don't know what's been
going on there was a huge cyclone that
hit Mozambique this week and it's very
very sad to see what's going on there so
hopefully those that are still in
trouble will be rescued and the rescues
hopefully you know get to a serious pat
on the back because it looks hectic to
say that least in Mozambique at the
moment it's you know such a flat country
and when you get these big cyclones the
whole place just floods and there's all
kinds of horrible stories of people that
are living on roofs of their houses and
have been for the last few days as you
know they wait for help to come so not
very pleasant and you are you think you
know is also the amount of people that
have died but it do you've got to think
about how many animals must have also
died from from that particularly
domestic animals things like dogs and
cats and the likes very very sad when
you get those kind of things that are
happening so you know as much as you
want water to fall out the sky it's
always terrible when it falls at a rate
that causes such massive destruction in
one area
anyway more positive thoughts still
haven't seen much this afternoon I don't
think we've seen anything since we saw
that Impala earlier I believe a lot of
you are agreeing about the whole
Mozambique situation and it's not just
most because for some Malawi and some
both northern Zimbabwe - that's in the
same fight
look Sebastian we found an animal same
ones yeah the same but we do have do you
have some new partners David updates on
who Comorian shadaloo they were I don't
know about today but yesterday morning
both Racine's should deliver seen with
the two cubs on arethusa moving about
and Komori was if you can believe this
because now remember that's Herkimer he
was seen on Juma and in the yesterday
would have been the next day since we
saw him he was all the way on the London
Losey boundary quite far to the west so
he must have walked himself stupid
during the course of that day and night
and so he was seen all the way down
towards London boundary on the manual 80
and Markham Sava which is Julie's
younger sister was also seen yeah we
hope Coomer he was as well some wonder
if he's not trying to mate with her down
that area but she'd be a bit early I
suppose it should be but young for that
so that's where they were I don't I have
no idea about today I haven't received
an update about either of them today but
I would imagine that should do news with
the Cubs and still on earth users
outside they saw her sort of waist
inside of arethusa
which means that she's not very close to
our boundary and therefore doubtful that
she would have crossed onto our side
today we can go and check out a little
bit later though if we have no luck
driving around we'll go and have a
little bit of a look but there really is
very little to go on at the moment we've
had zero alarm call zero tracks for any
Amy's or anything like that so very
tricky at least oh no not really
um quite some throat for Lauren that she
managed to see those two lipids this
morning but no not jealous it's always
nice to see lipids obviously and
but yeah I'm happy for her more than
anything else I think it's always nice
when we get lipids in the Mara you know
it's funny because it is the stigma
that's the Mara's got no lip is but it
it most definitely does it has a lot
more than people think
it's just that's these two combinations
that work against us for seeing a lot of
lipid in the mire a triangle one thing
is that we obviously spend a lot of time
in a certain area given the certain
animals that we like to follow like
sausage tree prior to you know all of
those kind of things and that's not very
lipid-rich
yeah because it's up towards the
escarpment and the open area things so
we don't spend nearly as much time where
a lot of the leopard sightings are the
second reason why we don't spend a lot
of time there and probably the major
reason is that most the lipids are seen
along the Mara River now south of Sirena
and there's a little bit of a kind of
dip that goes down towards Lookout
crossing and down to majima chavo and
BBC drainage in those areas and we get
no signal there and so going and looking
for the lipids in that area is pretty
useless unfortunately because we can't
really show you them and so that's why
the number of lipid sightings in the
mara for us is so so low it's just
because we can't spend times in time in
the areas where it's most productive for
the lipids so yeah I'm happy that she
got to see them I'm really glad that we
got both of them one on camera so it's
it's a female that's is believed to be
about 10 11 years old I'll give you some
history of this because I spoke to yeah
funny and I spoke to Adam randomly today
and then he was telling me about this
but she's about a 10 11 year-old female
and that's a young male that she's she's
got at the moment he's about 16 months
old they think and they know of three
previous litters to this one and they
one I think is a young male that's
hanging around the triangle stool and
then the others they're not too sure
about and they think that this bit of
this particular that say there was a
little mate but they can't confirm that
so she's seen quite a lot on the
northern bank close to serena every now
and then she comes across onto that
Southern Bank I believe she made that
gazelle kill yesterday
and she was senior and then obviously
again today which is very very cool so
really nice that she was seen like I
said not jealous at to his master and
everybody gets to see the spotted cats
and what I am jealous all I think is
that the Mara has been absolutely
heaving with animals of late I mean
between the sausages and all the Cubs
they've got the winners and their cubs
and Basara and you know lipids it's been
very good up that side of the world
Lauren will hopper Murray chase for
Sanne back to Juma and so the reason why
I say that is because
hasanah is not even in Herkimer his
territory at the moment he's on the
southwestern side of marthy which is
northern on Dalhousie it's the section
north of the Sand River of London Ozzy
and he say he's kind of down on the
southwestern side on the northern bank
of the Sand River that makes any sense
men haka Murray does not go they come or
he's not going to be the one to do any
chasing yet it would have to take flat
rock or one of those bigger dominant
hands and to push him from that side and
then get him kind of through Herkimer
his territory and then Herkimer he would
have to push him to to get him back this
side I think the one animal that is
probably the one that's causing a lot of
the trouble and why maybe husana left oh
it's tricky to know for sure because we
obviously didn't see any altercations
but I think that that I hadn't know in
mail which is ridiculous we need to give
him a name at some point because he's
being seen a lot he was on Mala Mala the
other day and has seen quite often by
the in quarrel guys and various guys
have tried en vessels you know I think
he might be the one that is probably the
one that's pushed her sauna a lot more
and the reason why I say that is just
there's about two or three days before
Sanne left actually might even be in the
day before if I think about it he was
seen exiting juma coming out from ton
dams
salivating heavily and normally when a
male lipid walks and he salivates like
that it's he's had an encounter with
another leopard and that could be male
or female - you never really know but
maybe he bumped into a sauna hispana
thought himself well between no camera
in the sky is just getting too crowded
around Chen moved off and headed off
towards Rondo's it could be that or it
could be that you know
time of the year maybe there's something
that husana kind of doesn't like yeah
and he pushes and he moves and and tries
to go and find food in other places
because he did the exact same thing
really last check sips he left in April
last year and then he came back in June
so it'll be interesting to see maybe if
it dries up maybe her son will come back
and this is just a pattern that he goes
through obviously he's not gonna be able
to do the better with his life because
he wouldn't be able to dominate that far
from here to London without other males
being around but it's gonna be
intriguing to see how it's all kind of
plays art and whether or not he does
come back I hope that he does well
either one he'll either him or tumba
needs to kind of make their way back
blundell eyes you can't have both are
you going to sign a petition and send it
to them and say that anyway I'm shaking
please don't do that how they're going
to hate me if you do and if every gonna
carry on we're not gonna stop looking at
the impalas and the impalas like please
once in the relief it's back here either
the compiler is like it's quite nice not
having so many lipids around but we're
gonna carry on I'm gonna see what else
we can find in the meantime back up to
David and see if he's got any of that
mara magic that they've been having over
the last few days weeks on the lower
part of Juma especially when Tristan
talks about them the video saying of all
the guides Tristan I think Azul is the
luckiest with leopards now I have stops
doing big mammals and I'm doing now
feathered friends and I have an eagle on
top of this tree and as much as I also
want to be one among you ladies German
ID won't you tell me which ego is this
hashtag Safari live on Twitter please
tell David what ego is on this tree and
I'll just tell you this tree is what we
call the East African green hut the
trees for the East African green heart
and even think that is a difficult name
to remember and you think you'd want a
simpler one I'll give you a simpler one
and you can call the tree one bugia yoga
dances so let me give you a simpler name
which is one Booga yoga dances is the
name of the tree and my question is what
but do you think this
is hashtag safari live on twitter only
one clue it is an ego does that help
okay do we give more clues always stop
there boom this is that is enough of a
clue for you to know who it is
well I think mgn great comment it's very
heavy ego and she is big bye bye in a
standard mgn ivory view she's pretty
heavy ego sorry about logic and yes do
you think this is I already give you one
clue as it is an ego and Jonathan
Ravinder brown snake ego good thinking I
could also be wrong but I do not think
so the one I'm thinking it is I do not
think that racing's brown snake he go I
highly doubt she's brown snake ego I'll
also go back to my book and find out and
Misha Bungay do not come to me
Lorraine Tony who I'll give you a whole
50% when he go for an ego I'll give you
Reza 150 % very very well done and you
have said it correctly is a juvenile but
lower ego wherever you are take my high
five and another high five from Bungay
very well done and the the the challenge
was is because she is young but if you
look on the head and look at how those
feathers are sticking out the stick in
the shape of a bat lower and that's
correct and that is a juvenile bats lua
ego a little bit of a greenish tinge on
the big very well done for getting it
correct they talk very good alright so
and this bass take a long time to mature
you see that color to adjust so there
they taken it in five six seven years to
see there are normal colors the massif
could easily see ok Bunga please if you
come here
I thank you very much now with such the
number seven a there which is bottom
left it's not I hope you have some good
glare there yes that looks good to me
and that's the juvenile but slower ego
now we'll move to the right to 7c there
and look at the difference between those
two birds which almost seem to be the
same size you see that they arranged the
black and the white on the adult
so from this fledging from this stage to
this stage sometimes is five to eight
years of course depending on e dividual
bars Wow
I'm happy that you got that one correct
so high five
I ten and we need to move on I think
I've done very well for getting that one
ego it's time maybe to go back to what
I've been thinking if I'm lucky I'll get
there is some rhinos or whole family of
Ellis
Al Jarreau you say wonderful but do you
learn from us I mean I'll tell you the
Masai Mara alone the Masai Mara alone if
I remember very well has more bad
species than North America and Canada or
the US and Canada combined together we
got mobile species only here in the Mara
than the US and Canada combined together
Kenya as a country alone we got over a
thousand species of parts and in Mara we
are talking about 450 bars pieces and
Mary the final controls goes wow that is
amazing I mean we used to get see the
guides I mean guess way back when I was
doing different guiding would only come
to Kenya and just enjoy budding and
every day we'll have book piece of paper
and pen and count the number of species
would see in a day and at times you'd
stop and you go wow look at that little
birds and will tell you well thank you
David for the leopard but what is that
small bar there in the tree
and I'll just stretch my head you know
thinking I'm exerting them with a
leopard and they don't care you can keep
a little party let's talk about the body
in the tree there and then occasionally
there'd be these small little bad
smaller buds or sometimes they haven't
gotten their pledges they haven't gotten
their feathers very well
courage Simone you like to know what's
layin territory I am in currently I'm in
the mash prides territory
mush fried but once in a while a rich
mom we have seen also the mara river
dried Chris pristine or overlapping with
Marsh pride but this area is mainly
meant for the mash right I haven't seen
the merits mom for a long time off I'll
see them today but this is their domain
but talk of the male's Eric's mom we
have also seen what we call the three
key tumors around here and my friend
Patrick so one of the kitchen Mel's with
the window pride the other day I do not
know what he was doing with them and
they're always three piece or one not
sure where the other two are
chances are he definitely joined them
for a meal and that's the pride that
David was talking about and he said it
was good to see alive
giraffe because of the pride that
brought down a giraffe so males bang big
sometimes being slow or not lazy per se
because that we have known we have seen
males you know getting their own food
but once they know they got prize around
and the girls
chop chop it quick to get food will
always get smells sneaking to any
clothes by pride and chanting on the
kills so that's why most likely that one
particular male was the oven plate I've
never seen it without prides you know
the times have been around here
been wonderfully good in terms of
weather the temperatures have
tremendously gone down which makes me
feel very very nice and some of animals
have been talking about for example the
Rhino
it could easily now come out the
thickets and maybe just coming up an
area and just like the giraffe we saw
earlier come and browse and small little
plants in the open or maybe go for a
drink by the marsh area who knows
princess Kimberly you asking when's the
last time is so bad Fox's for me it's
quite some time and if I am NOT wrong
addresses Kim Lee the last person to sue
the bastard Fox's was Steve bengay have
you seen the mullet Bungay he just goes
like this
meaning norm so apparently the roots
abscess is Kimberly I'm taking going
round the marsh like this I will end up
in a road where we have always known
they have den soon stay tuned don't go
any higher we might be seeing them today
well the grass is quite high but because
of them coming out of the day and every
time they tend to match the grass and
it's a guess so
so we'll just dry there we're gonna just
rise up a little bit and most likely
I'll be able to see them and unlike say
Jacko's which will always keep moving
from you know one area of when they are
looking for food the bat-eared foxes the
tent remain very close to their dens
without going very far
it's one area many times I've seen black
trainers either at the very edge of the
forest that you see in first for me or
when they come out
sorry Mari James has saved something
there if you don't mind coming back to
me sometimes we get our comes coming in
and disappearing very quickly before
they land in my ear
I definitely general get you yes Mahalo
continues with sports today because
today I think Lauren I'm not sure
whether she told me she won't call
herself the queen of the Mara in terms
of cuts because she had a wonderful job
this morning when she had two little
airports with a kill that was very
special to Lauren
hopefully that luck continues with us
today and now I had said I do not want
to coupons anymore because we heard the
juvenile bars luego but to see two lilac
beretta together makes me or gives me no
choice but to stop and if I had a good
camera I would have done like hundred
screenshots and Mary in the final
control no show Mary you have a camera
there you can use your phone I think you
have a bigger screen than my monitor
here and take as many pictures of
David's favorite bad and I do not want
to ask you who this is because you all
know the lilac breasted roller is a
lilac on her breast
that is what give her part of the name
and the other part she rolls on the
enroll in air when the emitting that's
how they got both names not a hundred
percent sure but I guess this could be a
male and a female morph in the note we
see them solitary but to see males and
females I think is pretty special and
talk of sexual dimorphism and that's
where we go wrong now the button wave
that we saw that was juvenile if you see
the fully grown ones the be no males and
females no gray area you should be able
to tell them apart
Riaan what is the best time to visit
tomorrow event Darian and anytime is a
great time now during the rainy season
is always a bit of a challenge because
Rianne during the rainy season you tend
to stick on the roads and we get stuck
but a time like now is this this is one
of the best times to visit Amara because
during the rainy season we get stuck and
we are not able to leave the big roads
to get close to the bats but a time like
now when you have neurons is a very good
time to come and do badging but I'd say
in general the Mara is wonderful all
around there with budding again as only
said when it rains you tend to be
restricted to the big roads only because
chances are you'd get stuck but with no
rains Ryan
anytime you're welcome to see such
lovely but like this ones here and to
see till them together is pretty special
I was talking a few seconds ago of this
sexual dimorphism of a certain species
of birds and I said the battery goes
black and white you can tell but this
one's always give us a little bit of a
challenge unless they get so close to
each other hopefully I have not
forgotten the male is only slightly
larger in size and than the female
that's only way you can tell the
difference when they are together but of
course if you're likely to see them
meeting you will know who the male is I
can see the female and I think this is
good
and see not cute like so how long these
but still together and I can tell you
sorry I do not have a very good answer
but I would say it's very short times
you know very few times you see them
together like it is yes you know in
general we see them in singles either a
male or a female is very few times we
see them together so our try and
guessing I can tell you they stay
together for very short time maybe the
issue after mating they go different
directions that's the only way I would
say butts enough I do not have a
definite timeline when this beautiful
bird
stay together see all the colors you see
in that small bar there and why would it
not be my favorite but in
whole world in flight whoo I mean you
just want to catch it and you keep it in
you know in your house as much as you
not want anybody keep these beautiful
birds as pets but in flying they're some
of the most beautiful birds
so sometimes can be patched up they're
looking on the ground
and they could be looking for anything
from insects apparently sometimes even
snakes
cleaning them it's very typical votes
just making sure
oh the feathers a good ship needs a gal
that's a good question why do the warmer
climates have more colorful bands I
think number one temperatures make a
whole difference I think that you can
you just heard me talking a few minutes
earlier saying that we got more bird
species in the Masai Mara area only more
than us and Canada combined together but
I think we have more tropical conditions
I would say one they have a big choice
of food and for reason they tend to
prefer it appropriate better and they
are always in general very colorful and
also nature girl I'm sure you know the
superb starlings you know how colorful
they are I had friends of mine who told
me they also got starlings notions in
America but not as colorful as here I'll
be maybe be finding out who my friends
maybe later on and know exactly who I in
warmer climates our birds here are
colorful look of tariqas nature go see
the tuna course that we have here are
equally very very colorful and I think
hopefully because where we are we're not
very far from a thick forest we might be
able to catch up attract women per se
the warmth makes them travelers food and
then the feathers we'll have all these
beautiful pigmentation
it's one of the sighting of heart with
lilac breasted rollers we vowed moving
and I would say seeing two together
which is quite special thank you very
much lilac breasted rollers
keep smiling and always give me similar
cooperation next time
alrighty Tristan in the update for us
please
bill David I'm envious of your Delilah
krysta trailers cuz I will take anything
at this stage of the game it's so very
very very quiet
Anjou minutes off scene I didn't
actually think I've heard somebody on
the radio for the last hour
the last updates I got was from James
saying he was following up on vultures
but that does the last I heard
hopefully you hasn't been eaten by
something that would be a bit awkward
but otherwise it's been seriously quiets
no one's talking which means nothing is
really happening and there's no tracks
even to follow up on which is
interesting you know you normally get
some tracks for like an Ellie or
something like that that kind of keeps
you busy for the afternoon but today
nothing and I'm surprised because we've
had not greats where the conditions in
the mornings and it's a beautiful
glorious kind of afternoon and it's not
cold it's not hot should I say it's a
it's kind of a nice temperature for
animals to be moving around so a little
bit surprised that we haven't seen so
apparently James has not been eaten
everyone don't panic you can calm down
he's alive and well
accepts Wendy as not alive and well he
has vehicle issues I believe so Wendy is
not doing very well you may have noticed
by not seeing James and hopefully James
will make it back otherwise we'll go and
fetch him don't worry we won't leave him
to survive the wilderness on his own and
need him out stranded with a broken
windy
and Craig the good thing is those many
of you might have noticed don't hear
that squeaking anymore
good old rusty is fixed did you notice
him
Howard lovely isn't it very pleasant to
drive around now without having that
irritating speak in one's ear so rusty
is back from the doctor say Marie you
want to know who fixed it and how did
they do it well a gentleman by the name
I should not see even say gentleman less
it should say magician by the name of
oppa who is our camp mechanic he got
hold of rusty yesterday for was just me
on the day before yes and he worked his
magic and it was quite funny because I
drove into Minnie and I said to him oh
boy this cars making too much noise it's
driving me crazy
then he said to me is the what kind of
noises I said no squeaking noise say his
eyes just lit up and he said don't worry
I'll have it back to you in an hour
and sure enough an hour later he brought
it back and it was no longer squeaking
so what it was I don't know but he knew
how to fix it
he also fixed stop Oh bonnet cables so
we can now open the bonnet once again
which is very very very nice so Rusty's
back in back in working order which is
very pleasant makes me happy when rusty
is purring like a little kitten and nice
and quiet exactly the Franklin that was
stuck in there has been removed now and
everything is all good which like I say
his good for step in my sanity because
the two of us is a morning where it's
just had money other than morning before
I can't remember said well I know is
that my eye was twitching by the end of
the drive was during the rain it was
hair
rain rain in the mornings never a fun
thing actually don't mind them a rain in
the afternoon like late afternoon but in
the
morning let's say nice
tamarah there we go exactly Wendy was
like you're gonna replace me I think not
well though it might've motivated James
to be replacing windy that much faster
now that she's broken down but maybe
she's just teaching James and listen
that she's actually in charge of the
game and not him and that he needs to
use to watch what he says bent on Drive
sitting driving around in one of our
petrol avenues they are I mean I I must
say you know it all jokes aside these
cars they they go through a serious
amount of abuse being driven around by
the likes of myself and James Henry and
brain clear Smith for as many years as
they have is really not ideal they've
been punished and put through their
paces and the fact that they still go as
well as they do and give us relatively
touch would not too much in the way of
issues you know we're very fortunate in
that we've got these vehicles the same
cannot be said about the Mara vehicles
that is a whole nother story on that
side of the world those vehicles are are
a pain in the backside if I'm honest
they really are not easy to keep running
mechanic on that side of the world is
shoddy who's also a magician this is
somehow keeping those vehicles living I
don't know how he does it they certainly
give us a lot more issues than what
these cause do you which is surprising
given the terrain that we drive through
yeah I think it's also that they just do
so many more kilometres in what what
these cars do you know will do on
average on a game drive here will be
probably about 20 kilometers of driving
whereas in the Mara an average game
drive is anywhere between 80 and 120 so
it gives you an idea it's almost three
times the amount of driving what is
three times the amount of driving that
they do in a single game drive within
what we do and so it's probably why you
find its cause deteriorates
that's much quicker I believe actually
kita and Milla are both at the moment in
the sickbay and just pucker that is his
driving around at the moment
okay so hopefully they'll both be fixed
soon
look the grass is long he said just
thinking nas as we driving the grass has
gotten incredibly long Lauren you say
you have no clue how they survived like
I say it's because we have two magicians
one here and one in the Mara and those
gentlemen puts in countless hours and
sweat and tears and blood into these
cars that keeps them running without the
two of them we would have been dead and
buried many many moons ago so we're very
fortunate in that we've got two very
very nice guys that always come to our
aid in a hurry and whenever we need it
and so you know we've we're fortunate in
that regard that we found two gems of
the world that look after our stuff so
nicely but it is a miracle that they are
still doing as well as they are I mean
rusty obviously looks good at the moment
because rest you in for a nice refurb
with oppa and you believe oppa is not
just a mechanic but he did a whole bunch
of panel meeting where can resprayed
rusty and made sure rusty is looking as
good as it is at the moment next one is
for Wendy obviously Wendy's going to get
her this sort of bodywork fixed because
she's looking a bit tatty at the moment
looking but rundown and then last but
not least will be jigger at some points
preju guys always the last one to get
looked at in the fleet's that's because
unfortunately jigger doesn't get worked
nearly as hard as what rusty and Wendy
do just for the simple reason that's for
me Jake is not mainly as comfortable no
is jigger I don't know I'd stand like
how did he get drives in comparison to
the other two if I'm honest that's
asking for call me isn't it I feel like
I'm asking for trouble with that
underneath feel like the next time I
Drive jjigae it's going to reaffirm just
how
how much trouble he can give me I'm
gonna get stuck some way or something
like that or Rusty's gonna break down
and I'm gonna have to drive Jigga for
like three months
as punishment for being nasty to jigger
anyway all right so back to our actual
finding of animals cuz we've been
talking about cars and things I guess we
in the West at the moment so this is
kind of scratching for any sign of
shadaloo or Camry given though they're
talking about them earlier it's an awful
off chance that they would be here and
so he just could be checking and in the
meantime we're going to send you across
to James who apparently has now fixed
Wendy and is back up and running
sorry about that everybody I got myself
waged on a stump well went for a long
walk
found absolutely no evidence of anything
whatsoever and then drove into one last
look under where the vultures were
sitting and got wedged on a stump and
then was very incompetent trying to get
off it because I didn't realize that in
fact the vehicles diff lock was not
engaging not a driver error involved in
the whole thing and in fact as I was
driving around thinking our smoothly I
was doing the job I was thinking to
myself how very unreasonable it was at
all the cam ops have voted me the worst
driver at wild earth and well as I was
having those thoughts about myself I hit
a stump and so it it seems that the
universe is telling me the same thing
that the cam up so so be it oh well I
did do a long walk through here along
the little drainage line that feeds into
the buffers of waterhole and
unfortunately I didn't come up with
anything at all so I don't know what
those vultures are looking at there must
be something here that has died will
being killed
so we'll do a loop around and then back
towards buffer look dam and hope perhaps
that whatever it is has decided that the
afternoon is quite thirsty and that they
need a drink I certainly feel like that
at this stage
anyway we'll have a look-see
otherwise it's just glorious being out
here I must say it was always in March
and April
even if there isn't an enormous amount
of wildlife to look at I don't even know
what you've been seeing in the Masai
Mara I assume both nice views and Epsom
Buffalo right will strive down here
nasty bit of road well road is a strong
term and then we'll have a look at the
waterhole once again and then I think we
shall just press on actually Tristan of
course is going to laugh of me heartily
I believe you've been looking at lots of
birds in the Mara that's good
as the video about the worst or the best
driver of safari life come out yet do
you know does anybody know this one
being made or has been made and has come
out I'm not sure if it has or not very
funny I think it's very funny anyway if
it hasn't come out it doesn't come out
yet so when it does I think you'll have
a good laugh at a lot of us
luckily no one took it particularly
seriously
ingenious thank you very much your
positive thoughts you say don't worry
driving is only 90 percent of a safari
well yes exactly the other 10% I'm okay
at just that 90 percent that are not
very good at because I'm short you see I
can't see over the top of the dashboard
I have to have the special cushion see I
had a special cushion made for myself
not only for myself of course it has
been made for true sharla and for Lauren
and Jamie as well I don't think any of
them use it I think it's just me Daniel
you are asking if I can see as the
dashboard Daniel I can I hope you choke
I don't really have you choke of course
that was just a joke
I will say I got in an uber the other
day now I don't know I'm suppose this
happens in all parts of the world when
people try to be very cool while they're
Drive and this uber man who must have
been about five foot six oh two inches
shorter than I am set something like
this I don't even make the seat do it
but he looked like this as I got into
the car and he said yo he said you know
where we're going he said yeah yeah
that's good
it'll feed Rove like this all the way
home and I at one stage I was convinced
that he couldn't see where he was going
because we got to a traffic light and he
was trying to see which lane to go in
and he kept doing this he kept doing
this to try and see whether where he was
going then what got into his left or
four cars had peeled off and tried not
to hit him he was back into his glory
just driving along like this
well sorry about that and sometimes
we'll have this picture breakups you
reminding where we are in Africa for us
to bring you all this wonderful sight
thing that we you know bring to you
every morning and every afternoon about
is it a month ago I was talking to a
viewer of course I was you know still
during the show and I was showing my
Phil right Preda volumes and I'm talking
about the trip ride and all the cabs
were out and this viewer told me
something interesting that he was in New
York
look at us and we are talking like
halfway around the world and who I am
and he told me you know what David
enjoying that side thing with you in
real time that was very special
now your imagine all the mountains the
hills the rivers the trees and all the
moisture in air so for us to get to you
that picture all those high-resolution
[Music]
sightings from here to there we faced so
many challenges but in general we are
always winning so once in a while we'll
face those agreements and we apologize
for what just happened there
but at the end of the day we'll always
put on our gloves and we tackle them
back in the camp you know we have some
wonderful team of engineers who do a
very good job and they'll always our
troubleshoot and find out over what is
the problem
and above all FOIA is the problem and
the other day one of the engineers was
talking about by the dub of Edwin you
just sit him over dinner and I don't
know that was him who started you know a
little talk over dinner table of all the
different departments we have you know
in safari life and then we had guides we
had the camera operators we had the
engineers we have the directors in the
final control we have the vision mixers
we have the producers not forgetting the
chests who do a wonderful job for us
and Edwin said who which departments do
you think is most important in the
company and I'll finish you the story
much later on and let's find out whether
James is winning or not
now I'm not a winner everybody I'm a
loser today I'm afraid I'm going to
leave
there was nothing above look damn I'm
gonna leave the area and see if we can't
find something else I guarantee you that
a Tristan came bungling past year just
because he'd given up where he was he'd
probably find whatever it is that we're
looking for anyway we'll keep going I've
decided to replace my cushion because I
couldn't see out of the dashboard like
the univer man he's already well driving
like that and the bush was another thing
to drive in Johannesburg like there
anyway let's see what that's interesting
biology we can find out here there's
another vulture up top there I'm not
gonna try and show him to you because
I'm gonna be irritating for Craig
because he's just sort of hiding in the
brown shirts but maybe if we drive
slowly around here we'll be lucky
looking in all the tops of the trees any
signs of alle pod
it's unfortunate Sunday meal
mmm tracks of anything around here I
must say ah wonderful
let's get across Kristen who's found
which is described as a live animal in
the form of a hyena indeed we do have a
live Adam although you could be mistaken
for it looking like it's dead the way
that it's lying down hyena is past art
and very very very sleepy at this stage
and its concept blame it I suppose it
was um you know we've got a warm often
I'm too hot but it's warmish and the
sun's been out and given that they spend
a lot of their time moving around at
night I suppose now it's like early
morning for them in their world and
that's why they're having a bit of a
rest night you can see not breathing
too fast in fact hardly breathing at all
now she stopped breathing she was
holding her breath sips just trying to
scare you and see how long it takes her
now she is breathing it's just very very
she is breathing I promise you um it's
getting a bit quiet here that she's just
kind of yeah there the ears twitched and
so definitely is breathing and is alive
but in a state of complete recline at
this stage of the game and I'm not can't
say that's I'm too surprised it's a
little bit early to come to the den we
are at the den for those of you
wondering and we thought we just pop
past because we hadn't found anything
else and we thought we'd just come and
have a little look quickly it is a
little bit early for these these little
ones to be art they generally only
emerge around sort of six ish so about
half an hour's time they should come out
but we thought we're just in the off
chance that they were moving about that
they would be here we'd come in check
but the good news is we've got one of
the adults and so when you're an adult
it's going to make life a lot easier
because a little ones will come bounding
out a little bit later in the afternoon
so we'll probably what we'll do is we'll
it'll spin a bit of time now and then
we'll probably go for a little bit of a
drive and just check treehouse and
turndowns once more and then come back
here
and try and see if the little ones come
out of it that is a serious serious
snooze that is taking place our but
jealousy actually say bye you jealous
she looks very happy
the wind is she doing yoga breathing
well I'm not sure if it's yoga breathing
or just sigh in a state of complete
comatose and happiness at the stage that
she's breathing sort of so shallow and
not really breathing quickly she's got a
nice little spot there if you kind of
see she's in the shade as you can see by
a kotas there's no sunlight on it and
she's got a little depression there
where her kind of side can go into and
then a little pillow is the sort of
apart and she can just put it pop her
head up on there and be as comfortable
as one could imagine certainly looks
comfortable don't know if it is animals
always make things comfortable exactly
there we go merry happiness and
depression there we go
but now she's she seems as though she's
perfectly comfortable and just taking it
easy hopefully she'll wake up to start
so it's nice when they wake up because
they often are the ones that'll get the
little ones to move about you know it
would be nice if we if we see the little
ones come out I have yet to see the
small small babies I've seen obviously
June's Cubs and pretties Cubs as well as
little plonk but I haven't seen a tiny
of the ones of ribbons yet so waiting
for them to come out I'm pretty sure
they will I think it's just gonna take a
bit of cooling down a little bit more
than what it is now and the Sun tick
it's slightly lower before they think
about emerging the best time for hyena
dens I find is always in the mornings
and this is generally quite a lot of
activity in the mornings it can be a bit
more hit and miss because a lot of the
time the adults might still be out and
scavenging or hunting or whatever
they're doing and they haven't quite got
back yet but if they do come back then
they can often be a hive of activity
particularly if they bring back a
carcass and then it's just absolute
pandemonium as the little ones chase
each other around all over the place in
view of the carcass and go crazy so it's
a good time of the day to be in the
mornings I mean afternoons sometimes you
can
lucky if it's cool enough and then they
they come out but what I think also have
notice I was at mass speaking to Jamie
that I've really spend so little time
around these hyenas of late and so you
know I don't really know what's been
going on here but from what Jamie tells
me she says she might think that maybe
protein coke he might have actually
moved in the because she hasn't been
seeing much of them the last few days so
be interesting to see if they actually
do show up here in the next few days or
weeks but since we get got a bit of a
heart beat in the form of an animal it
seems like David has followed suits in
the Mara and is giving us a cat for our
Sunday afternoon yes hyenas will always
have a lot to Tower and the some of the
most intelligent animals we got and I'll
say we are getting lucky you remember
alia Zaine as the cools off we get more
live we get more action and I have
picked up all we have found ourselves
some two lionesses now my guess is these
two belong to the marsh pride and the
two gums just in such a nice open area
and I just passed them and after I
looked on my right I saw something
flicking there initially I first saw
this chakra see the jerk moving to the
left here it's what you call a blocked
back Jack was live about Jacko and as
tough to just to find out what the jerk
would be doing but looking carefully
I saw something flicking a tail from the
grass because initially the one lioness
you Syria was flood completely in the
grass and I thought that looks like a
very weird jackal that's either on the
ground while the other is moving and on
using my father cuz I'm talking on my
binoculars is I found out it was a
lioness so the other one is on her left
flat flat which is very typical of lions
in the middle or when still rather warm
but this one now is looking at their
surrounding
on a possibility maybe over a meal later
in the day
well from where I am Mario likes also to
double confirmed or this is as much
pride but I would be happy if any of the
viewers could have a different feel of
who I got but I was thinking because I'm
not very far from the mass pride I would
guess so but maybe ladies and gentlemen
because you are always our experts
please tell me if anybody would think
otherwise I'd be very happy to know but
I'm so so close to the marsh criteria
and that's why I guess it could be that
or maybe the mash breakaway possibility
of those two prides is Ronnie I have not
been for a very long time and especially
when they are not looking at you and
they're fitting the other way it could
be different well ladies and gentlemen
hash tag Safari live on Twitter if maybe
possibly you'd be in a better position
to tell me which these two girls are at
least we have one that we can see and so
the difficult to tell who they are
especially if you don't see their faces
the fish will always tell us a lot and
little scars on Geonosis and it was
split they may have liked the main Kulii
some Todd or Tony years or some the eyes
could be a very light or very dark like
Limpy the one likeness in the sauce you
probably know her eyes and kinky are
very light so it could be some all those
countries that we look at she's now
facing in the direction we are in oops
just faced away and hopefully you'll be
able to tell me who you think these two
themes are and especially the one just
laying down in that particular direction
but my guess would be either Marsh pride
or the marsh breakaway because I'm not
very firm about what for kilometers or
three kilometers from the marsh pride
just rightly under two miles from that
area and who is that spotted hyena what
are you up to
it's very interesting to have seen
Jolyon and no hyena and his two girls
don't seem to be eating anything dressed
good question
harmony prides harmony quality hoops
good question out same for the pride in
the Mara let's talk with the Mara Troy
well you know the mayor is so huge we
have what you call the main trauma a
triangle and the main the main Mara we
are based in the Mara triangle and the
murder triangle alone has over ten
tribes over 10 threads the other side of
the Mara would cost called main Mara has
also out guessed about 15 prides now
where we are we can easily identify the
ten prides for you so and the other
surprise the coalition's mainly we have
or to call the cute Romans because you
don't have as many coalition as prides
because the coalition's will be moving
from one plate to the other so we have
in the same exactly same sport I am we
have what we call the key Chalmers which
are always three and further south to my
favorite part of lions that we call the
sausage pride we have the old owner Pike
and not far from there we have another
coalition that has another male that is
called bully we all know of Kapali
and then we have one young star that is
always hanging around with Owen pride
which we think should be having you know
equality and pretty soon and as you move
towards the Mara River me allows that
recourse arena
we got another quali on there that you
call the Scarface then we have another
coalition that you call it jelly boy
button to that initially were nomadic
males or they seem to be having home now
because one lioness houses so Rose risen
up let's have a quick look at it but the
price many many one the marsh pride to
the marsh breakaway three the Mara River
pride for the Magura pride five the you
know pride six this
you prayed seven they sort lik pride and
I should be going to ten three I mean
eight the Paris pride I have always
comfortably counted ten price who am I
losing the other two but I've always
known for a fact I could identify for
you about ten different
oh the oh no how would I forget the
owner of pride come on Boone gay you
need to wake me up boom gay if you can
give me a cup of coffee
the owner little pride and all honor
pride have been like the largest pride
we have here but we got the sausages
that have come in and if I'm correct the
sausages got ten cups and now five
females 15 to quality mayor's 17 if
nothing changes in the dynamics of that
pride particular pride it will be the
largest pride they are more a triangle
yes tenth pride yes he got now the
island on your pride yes I've always
known ten prides very good so and it's
leave these two guards and again as I
say should anybody be a hundred percent
sure which pride this could be I just
guess I'm the marsh right or the marsh
breakaway please let me know
hashtag Safari live as we take you down
to South Africa to Tristan with his
spotted Highness nice it David found
some lions and hopefully we'll figure it
out as to who they are as you can see um
jeans little ones are arts and about sin
exploring we haven't seen ribbons yet
but it's no surprise as the students are
arts given that she's the one lying yeah
and they've kind of been moving around
sort of sniffing and being as naughty as
they K one of more tea actually they've
been very good they've been biting
everything they're all the little
branches and things now being blessing
and chomped on the one is very
adventurous third one has gone towards
the pan that is behind us and then this
one looks like it's going to follow suit
and also head off in that direction now
it's a very odd sound that is coming
from our northern side at the moment and
recon work out exactly what it is
sounds like baboons but not quite
I was gonna stop talking for a bit I
swear I listen carefully
it's a very odd sound that's been coming
from that and recognize it's a weird eye
view it sounds like it's getting closer
you perverts actually but a very odd
call for them it's not their normal sort
of a long haul that they'd give for
something like a leopard maybe it's an
alarm call finest that they're giving
off they do have different alarm calls
for different predators for like birds
of prey or little lions the thing is it
can't be something that is easily
Carnival BDI it's a bit freaky that like
in the centre of the image but it can't
be something that is too interesting
because it was an alarm call for
something like let's say in parlors of
kudu or something that this hyena
recognized as potentially another animal
it would have been up and listening a
lot more entertaining than what it is
you can see she's kind of half watching
us half not pretty awesome visual of a
hyena eye that's for sure yeah you're
gonna wake up now to little the little
hooligans are coming back now yeah
that's the lighter of the TuneIn is the
darker one that's he and it should be a
what's actually hopefully six these guys
pretty well this one's got its but it's
kind of what would we call it its
genitals as probably the best weird
hanging out both of them actually have
been walking on so if we can get a nice
close-up shots of them maybe some of you
can screen shots and figure it out
come on little one there we go so you
guys are gonna have to try and figure
out whether or not that is boy or girl I
don't know if Jamie's figured out jeans
Cubs he it's a contra him if she said
yes or no Oh as to whether they have
been sexed obviously very tricky with
Cubs you generally need to get about
three months before you can actually be
six my unit comes they're not the
easiest to tell you've got a look at the
shape of their phallus essentially and
so if it's got a very straight into it
then it is a female if it's got a
triangular tip then it is a male so
that's how you're able to tell the
difference between the two you now this
is the darker of the two you can see
it's still kind of gaining its spots it
hasn't quite gotten as light in color as
the other one
dillan Davina's have a good sense of
hearing and now
No
I have no idea and sorry also this is a
ribbon not Jun that I said earlier the
ears I looked at even once we saw
initially so you can see there lots of
kind of tears in them I think it's his
ribbon I haven't seen ribbon engages
actually it looks like yeah here's
Sharon she's got yeah she's been
hammered unfortunately actually saw when
it is we're quite badly kind of chomped
up but I wonder what caused those little
ones to run maybe they saw were the
other little ones or I don't know what
it is they just kind of all of a sudden
got a bit of a fright and went running
off towards the den the ribbon doesn't
look too kind of stressed by anything
living Agency has kind of gone back to
having a bit of a nap so not sure what's
causing those little ones to be a bit
distressed maybe they just got a
frightened bird flew over or something
like that and that's why they went
scuttling wolf
there's one
it also explains why the approach
towards ribbon is not one of kind of
going and suckling in muzzling up to
them and playing you know these little
ones will be from a different mom and so
they would not suckle from from ribbon
still intrigued by the sounds tip I'm
not sure its verb its I wonder if we
should go and check it out just to see
and then come back yeah might be worth
it right this little one got a 5-2
something above its it is busy
investigating the tree and so while we
go investigate the Sun to see what it is
we'll come back just now let's send you
to James with a bid
unfortunately our story has flown away
and you just move forward there's a very
very interesting story playing out here
what we've got is a Great Spotted cuckoo
right there
zoom straight in there no that's a Chris
Bob it is it yes but a Great Spotted
cuckoo that is any hair being fed by its
virtual Starling hosts so it's very
obviously a juvenile and I'm just gonna
be quiet while you listen to pretty u
can hear that kind of Swizzle acquire
that's the cuckoo and it's calling the
Starling and super the grass moving
there it's calling the Starling down and
the Starling we've watched it feed the
cuckoo once I thought it was attacking
it for a second until Craig sat there
and I was feeding it
and what's interesting is that I suspect
that cooking must be about to leave now
those of you unfamiliar with cuckoo
biology they obviously never meet their
own offspring right so that thing's
parents would have laid well its mother
would have laid an egg inside the
virtual starlings nest and I suspect
it's in the dead tree just behind us and
then flown off and the nature of birds
or most birds is such that they would
never have realized that they were
raising someone else's chicks so they
would have thought that that great
spotted cuckoo would look at absolutely
nothing like them was they're just
slightly yeah I suppose
unattractive offspring now then they
will fly off to war they're all migrate
every single cuckoo we get tear migrates
the great spotted cuckoo I think is a
Paley Arctic migrants so some heart
knows how to go here to Eurasia it is
indeed a very Arctic there are a number
of different subspecies actually so some
of them in fact do remain in Africa
northern African southern Europe anyway
I don't know which one that was but some
youngsters take or will spend in their
first season here and I just want to see
when they normally leave South Africa
let's see if I can do that
identification years voice yes
distribution population migrations of
movements October to March median
arrival date 12 October 2 parts second
half favor in early March later May in
Libya and occasionally over wintering
juveniles leave later than adults okay
that's very interesting
the paly Arctic breeding birds do not
move south of the Equator
so this chap must move into North Africa
and perhaps very southern Europe and
then fascinating no Steve I don't think
the chicken knows that those aren't its
parents I think it just grows up baking
from whatever it meets when it first
hatches from the egg and that's what
feeds it I don't think it has sufficient
self-awareness to know that it looks
absolutely nothing like its parents and
in fact the funniest part of watching
these birds often is that they get much
bigger than their adoptive parents and
you find them still begging for food
despite the fact that they are much
bigger than the birds that are feeding
him an interesting story anyway we've
got quite a good view but these cookies
very seldom sit still for long enough
very nice okay on the go Suns gone down
now certainly is in the process of doing
so I've been seen any checks of anything
else so we'll just keep on enjoying our
afternoon I think
dad Tristan went off to the hyena den
that was a good idea certainly would
have been what I would have done this
time the day Circe
even a slight sign of an elephant since
I've been back and I believed that they
were around pretty much until I got back
please
we'll go back fast twin dams and then up
the east again and see if it something
hasn't come down for an evening drink
and we'll probably travel there via of
the little bit of Marty
that's this riverbed yeah
yes all you can tell what type of bird
laid an egg if you find an egg they're
all very different some people are
experts in that sort of thing and the
Cuckoo's eggs actually often looks like
it's how they can somehow disguise their
eggs to look like their hosts eggs which
i think is rather remarkable very
interesting I'm not particularly good at
doing that I don't recognize
eggs particularly what is their fun to
us I think this did you think that was a
leopard look Craig and I found a leopard
we didn't really it's a piece of sort of
dark bush there we are there you go I
bit that off that that fooled you for a
second when you saw the little white tip
on the bottom of that piece of bush
both got so excited
alas it is just a stick no it's a number
of sticks actually a collection of
sticks yeah almost exactly like a
levered Greg I'm sure everyone else has
fooled as well
lots of grass
lots of long grass
anyway said guess
gosh Craig pan or pan around and listen
and so we go into the changing of the
gaurd which was of course the changing
of the cameras in the Maasai Mara
ah we just get mushy very well
ladies gentlemen I might be having some
news for you just hold on for two
seconds and we might frame something
exciting for you right and there and
then tell me what is not well I do not
trust the Christian asks to alia of The
Bachelor ego we all know this he's has
putted cut and I remember Murray in the
final control who is the director today
saying hopefully we are going to
continue with our lack of our animals
and that one there is a cheetah not sure
where she wants to go but give me two
seconds I might want to reposition
myself if you allow me so that today we
have been doing very well this morning
it was Laurie
maybe this morning us forward let's go
let's go pack up I can move forward
because we also need to identify who
this God well this cheetah is here so as
she wants have a drink how is that going
stop
you
well unfortunately it sounds like
there's a few gremlins where their
cheese is and as you can see we sitting
with some kudos at the moment this is
not what was making the alarm called
this by the way before everybody thinks
that these are why are we sitting here
it's not if it turned out actually which
is really interesting it's the first
time I've ever ever ever heard this
particular animal make the sounds that
we were hearing we thought it might be
kind of a weird vervet cork sort of
making that kind of strange sound but it
was actually a 20 eagle that was being
mobbed by birds other birds and it was
making this kind of weird sound I've
never heard a Tony make that sound
before so it was super interesting
unfortunately in flew away before we
could kind of get it on camera so not
ideal but it was very very cool to see
and that played us things three stumbled
into the canoes that she asked them and
we thought well we'll just have a quick
look at them and while we're here and
then we'll go back to the hyena den
shortly but very very cool to be kind of
eye level with them and there is that
one that was in the long grass
unfortunately had moved there that runs
can take its place but it's like a sea
of grass between us and them and you can
see a few ox pick is that on the kudu as
well and are driving them mad with the
years particularly imagine big ears like
that must be tricky with seem quiet
alert don't they don't hear anything
I suppose this time of the day they know
that it's being around the water sources
or is a chance that something is there
so that's maybe why she's looking the
way that she is good we're gonna head
back off to the iodine and go and
probably finish up our evening there in
the meantime back to you David and a
spotted cat that is rather speedy well
ladies and gentlemen number one my
apologies we had a picture break up and
you lost me
not sure who had a similar situation in
South Africa either James or Tristan
this time it was me and my apologies
well number two you might be wondering
what color is this cheetah well it gets
much darker here quickly than in South
Africa and that's why our cheetah looks
to be like in black and white because we
are already using infrared it's a bit
dark here and if I look at my watch is
about 7 o'clock old is about 6 o'clock
in South Africa and they are still in
daylight and the still in color so
that's why I watch it looks different
and Bungay has been able to switch from
that that's normal camera to this very
special one which we use and we do not
disturb the animals when you are
watching them now she has climbed up a
small hill Bunge if you go back right
there to my 9 o'clock or 12 o'clock
she's right this what about a do Bungay
before you go there why don't I back up
because I've seen her where she has come
out and this could be very exciting
because she was some very tough tickets
which could be very difficult for us to
drive into and she has come out in a
more better open area you just have to
do back up slowly and I'm sure after
having a drink because she was drinking
she'll come and give us some better
profile cheetahs unlike leopards will
not steal tickets they normally prefer
open areas where they can see themselves
and where they can also see their prey
ideally there's so many challenges
and leopards will go for Cheetos let's
go for them and I can see how I've been
run I've just stopped right there boom
gay if you don't like my anger let me
know and I'll give you the angry want
she has come out of the water in a very
nice open area and look at her
my guess this is Beshara and how lovely
to catch up with lions and a few minutes
later to see but cheetah lots of
Franklin's making a lot of noise and
definitely some of them in this part
which each other like oh they're not
very happy with them and this is very
special for us very good madam what
position you have put yourself into so
because she has come in an open area I
just have to move like five meters maybe
you'll have a bit look on her face what
we do we usually don't get very close
not to disturb them as much as I said
earlier we got that very special camera
that will give us a wonderful profiles
and maybe we might be able to confirm
100% this is Basara and i think either
yesterday or the day before Lauren the
queen of the cards we make all her hard
these cards now let's find out who this
is and my guess is vicious but Sarah
hello there
what did you see so they normally like
bang in such vantage areas high places
in a passage they can see 360 places
they can spot either prey or any enemy
that would be coming to them where do
you want to go do you want go for a hunt
who knows people have always said
cheetahs Diana cheetahs hunt during the
day but you'll be surprised even in
darkness cheetahs will hunt I have seen
a couple of times and the other sausage
republic associate of public see the
places he the sausage tree pride I have
seen cheaters in that area there too
that we call the Buddha boys I've seen
him hunting in total darkness but of
course you are like to offer them and we
saw them slowly following some Thomson
gazelle and we knew they would hunt
she's moving to a particular direction
and not sure why should be gone it's not
anything we have seen there but it has
cooled off and because you know cheetahs
are fast runners and speed is very vital
for them with low temperatures like this
I'm not surprised if you take a chance
maybe you on a Tony or run gazelle
romance good question
you Goomba and Canoga you're asking
whether we have any updates sadly not or
rather unfortunately not but Rome at
great question we are always very proud
of you should we hear any update on Jim
we'll be more than happy to let you know
immediately
so as you're sure we know you always
switched on will not let you know about
key Goomba and Kedah go on the very fast
able to get either from our friends
we've got so many guides that we are
always in touch with in the merit
triangle and also I'm sure you might
have known by now the game Rangers we
have from a very good family and they'll
always text us or send us some messages
telling us what they have found out and
where exactly it is so we'll let you
know trying to go to tummy bounds having
a look surveying scanning possibility
flick in the town we have always thought
you know when cats flick the tails like
that is always an indication of good
spirits we just saw her belly which
looked to me in very good shape so she
has disappeared in us about your
depression and of course and see the
grass is quite tall so what I want to do
is to turn around and see if we're gonna
catch up with this last-minute cheetah
which is dressing I'm a day
we're gonna Revis and try and catch up
with that cheetah and James Henry want
to talk of some maybe superiors on a
tree hello everybody here we have got a
squirrel not quite a cheetah
lisara or otherwise but a little family
of squirrels and as a youngster and
they're just enjoying the last bits of
light there you go you won't see one
sticking its head out but like my
nephew's had their bath put their
pajamas on but still they like to just
go outside on a gorgeous evening like
this and have a little bit of a play I'm
and dad's probably tirelessly cleaning
up their rooms might be mum they're
actually about to pour herself a stiff
drink and the embers of the day slowly
fade
a pretty little scene and I'd like to
live up there but for the fact that of
course a snake could get into my house
I'm afraid Mary all I got from those
calms were DuBose Pola DuBose I don't
know what that means
it's quite safe fun place to live
doesn't it
there we go poor apparently who said hey
squirrels hey squirrels yes indeed
yay squirrels thank you
I smell at this time of the year as well
of course because all the grass is long
so it smells quite fertile it's all in
seed
childhood the universe depends in
Thailand with the schools from so this
is obviously a squirrel of the
northeastern corner of South Africa it's
not a region known for wine growing but
squirrels generally a wine drinkers as
opposed to any other kind of spirit
drinkers but they're not particularly
fussy in this region so I suspect just a
fairly average red plonk is what it
would go for there we are possibly even
from a box if you go down to Cape Town
of course much like the people there the
squirrels pretend to know a lot about
wine and will thereby it according to
its price and so the more expensive it
is the more delicious they tell you it
is despite the fact that it all tastes
pretty much the same of course it
doesn't which in Cape Town well
very good
there's new had little home on a limb
sticking out over the earth back there
you're wonderful
very good I gradually prison see what
else we can find
we found a squirrel and two Impala and
sour man will come for the day
impressive
by squirrels
all righty I have failed to find more
mammals but Tristan is back with his
high he knows well
one can imagine this world sipping wine
in the Cape and having a good time I'd
like to know from James what he thinks
the squirrels of this area seem to drink
because they behave like hooligans so
maybe they into the brandy and coke
which is a big popular drink here in
South Africa we often see a lot of
people drinking brandy and coke
particularly in a very cheap quality
brandy normally but anyway as you can
see we're back at the high end again we
thought we'd just come back to see if
the littlest ones would come out given
that their mom is close by but so far no
sign of the little ones they might be on
the other side of the den there's two
entrances to this particular den this
one where you can see one of June's cubs
sitting and then there's another
entrance on the back side which we can't
unfortunately see at this stage so if
the little ones are sitting on the
entrance to the team we're not gonna be
able to see them
now it's all very very quiet this
evening bar the hyenas that are kind of
sitting in maybe nothing creaming
themselves you can see that one's having
a good scratch and unfortunately I would
imagine that this particular thing is
covered in fleas at the moment given how
long it's been used for I mean it's been
a good two months that they've been here
now what a month and a half should I say
that they've been around this area and
and that means that they have
accumulated quite a few little fees
given that they were at one time seven
of them moving about in this particular
area and so scratching is going to be
the order of the day you can see Rubens
gonna give herself a good groom now this
little one try just starts again suckle
from her then of course she had no luck
whatsoever it had no luck I'm we haven't
62 yet given that it's not Robyn's Cubs
she's not gonna let these little ones
actually have look but it's eerily still
tonight I haven't heard really anything
from the sort of nocturnal side yet
there's been very few calls
at all I suppose it's that time of the
day now where we kind of all the
daylight's animals are starting to stop
and it's about to come they're kind of
peaceful time where it's just in between
the nocturnal and the diurnal sort of
sounds and Bush goes very very very
stories at this time that you want to
hear that sore a booming roar of a lion
it's just a nice sign - yeah whipping of
hyenas - is also very nice at this kind
of time because often the time when if
you come out you and you're on a safari
you'll stop and have a son Darla no sir
as James is alluding to it might be a
glass of wine if you're a squirrel from
the Cape Birds most people will have a
gin and tonic
and when they come at this time of this
sort of nights and then you'll find that
they kind of spend up at a time enjoying
the sounds and so it's good when you
having that to have a nice big booming
ross or like I say Haines whooping
always makes me what are you very
excitable for the sort of evening
section of their drive where the
spotlights come out and you kind of
slowly bumble your way home from your
drink stop or you head to an established
sighting and kind of spend some time so
hopefully we'll get that at some point
but not it's at least look at how this
little one is approaching not so sure is
it lots of sniffing but no real no
you're not a welcome go away I don't
want you near me
fly is also unbelievable here this
evening you can see the ears are
constantly twitching and that's because
of those little fuzzy oh no go away
cheeky is the cool one anyway we can see
general see how brave this is one is the
new if it approaches any place in the
meantime back up to the cheetah with
David in tomorrow
well yeah when it becomes like this time
of the day flies would always follow the
hyenas and there could be a bit
irritating and I'm sure systems not very
comfortable but yeah I got a very
comfortable cheetah who is watching if
you look carefully in about another 40
or so meters in front of this cheese you
can see the eyes glowing in in your
screen but at the very back there I have
seen four Thomson's gazelles
now Thomson's gazelles consist 50% of
what cheetahs hunt but of course the
exceptions depending on what food is
available but here in the Mara is not
out 50% of what they prey on and the
tummy's sometimes you call them soon but
also then there'll be other
availabilities of grounds gazelle or
impalas or if you get the Musketeers for
example they'll bring down even a
wildebeest baby zebra a baby topi I say
Dalia cheetah have always been said to
be the animal but their cases when
cheetahs could also be active at night
and I have seen them hunting well he's
not showing any indication for hunt
aren't the moment but before she laid
down Jolla she is she had spotted those
four tummies so the trees hit top left
of your screen if you look to the right
of it via 2 tons of gazelles feeling
there very faintly they're quite a
distance maybe in fact three let me see
the movement you can see two moving
towards the right there they are
so we only gonna spend a few minutes
here and of course knowing how shy or
how sensitive cheetahs are we may give
us piss the moment we'll see her having
all signs an indication of going for a
hunt but at the moment she's just
looking and not doing much let's go back
to trace and find out that she knows
you've got some cuts or spotted hyenas
well we just had a brief glimpse of the
little ones coming out ribbon came to
the entrance and kind of made her little
low grumbling sounds and the little ones
came out for a bit and then she's gone
back the other side now so I'm just
gonna reverse back to see if maybe she
settled on the other side and the little
ones might come out for a suckle but we
got a view of the cute little faces the
two rubbishes are now the side I'll call
them radishes because they are the
naughty ones that are all over the place
but let's just go back in just check of
course if Ruben has left and we are
going to leave - I know you two are
coming the side can you see ribbon there
I can't see her and the reason why I say
we will leave is because I don't like to
spend time at the den without an adult
present at this time of the day
far too many other nasties that move
around in this area like the likes of
hooker Marie and the rest and if they
see a vehicle they might come
investigates and tried to got these
little ones so you know if there's no
adults in we leave these guys to
themselves if there's metal present then
it's okay to stay in staying in parade
it's nothing to do with the kind of
lights it's just more security of the
little ones now you're going to see a
game of biting and pulling by the ears
I'm sure these two are incredibly happy
that the older ones have left because
the last time I was here they were being
pulled by their ears by pretties cubs
and moving dragged around all over the
place right they'd disappearing that
side let's quickly go check it for a but
I stole their fur but it's not there
then we're going to carry on
they'll come back this side cause I
think this is the side that they like to
go in and if they're feeling a little
bit threatened mmm whose ribbon there
there she is
so Minami why are female hyenas bigger
than males well generally due to the
fact that they are more dominant within
within the group remember that it's not
always the case that females are that
much larger than males it does happen
but it can be in that males are of equal
size sometimes but usually it's because
of the dominance factor within hyenas
females often are the matriarch of the
clan and therefore that kind of role
that they take on allows into to
developing it begins stronger and they
then you know produce a little bit more
kind of testosterone and grow a little
bit bigger than the males sometimes it's
like I said not always the case but
that's the reason it's just the role
that they that they are that they have
within the sort of clan is you know the
dominant side of the sexes if you want
to call it that two females tend to be a
lot more dominant in the male is
although they are cases of males
dominating a clan and obviously males do
inherit two females lineage and her sort
of rank when they born so you know it's
it's not always the case that females
are that much larger than males it's a
bit of a misconception that they they
massively larger animals all the time
but in some instances and certainly
within the gym okay and the females are
bigger in the males and Sidney much more
bulky then what the males are and that's
due to the fact that the females in this
particular van are hugely dominant over
the males at this stage now our ribbon
is lying in the worst possible spot you
can see just to you know I and so I'm
sure the little ones are probably
suckling em really nicely I'm just down
the slope but we're never going to be
able to see inside there unfortunately
and that's because of the sort of
relative
sort of depth of that slope and and
where we parking we don't park on top of
the din and so you're not going to be
able to see the little ones unless they
finish suckling and they come poke up
their heads close to where their mom's
head is at the moment but very very cute
to see them they saw them very briefly
they just kind of came out and said
hello in this tiny tiny tiny little
black and a balls of fluff it must have
met when hyenas are these ages where
they swollen kind of black like that so
these are the ones where the spots are
just starting to show they are and
creatively cute you know in quiet kind
of got roughed up around the ages as
they do in they get a bit older and not
as an odd-looking I mean they of this
age ribbon did you have to lie they go
Debbie yes hyenas are very territorial
and will mark the territory regularly
and they don't mark the territory quite
like a cap does in that a capital
sprayer and these guys do what's called
anal pasting and so they have a little
gland that's underneath the anus that
they walk around and they'll paste
they'll secretes a paste from that that
they'll wipe on grasses and that will be
their way of marking their territories
obviously they also do difficut in your
own eye too but really the pasting is is
their huge marker that they lay down
when patrolling around and yes they will
patrol as well you must remember that
hyenas because they live in these
tight-knit family groups there's always
going to be other hyenas on the borders
that are in their own family groups and
so they will patrol to try and keep them
heart and allow them to have resources
for dens and food and water and all
those kind of things so hyenas are very
very much active patrollers and like I
say they do you actively mark territory
as well it's quite odd just to have half
a hidden in here kind of poking out of a
dingy sort of termite hole
the other little ones I think by the
looks of things have found themselves a
little spot right up from the on the
mound where you can't really see them
they kind of hidden behind bushes and
look very happy with themselves up in
the top there you can just see a bit of
movement every now and then in that
little area
they driven I think is suckling them and
then she's probably going to leave
that's what I would imagine is going to
happen with these guys is that they can
have a really good feeders at once and
then they're gonna be put back in and in
Reubens going to leave and she's going
to go and try and find food for herself
Janet yes so ribbon is in Tina's mother
I don't weigh in teammate is I haven't
seen if since I've you know been back
but yes she is in Tina's mom it's crazy
to think that in tema I remember said
when we used to go see little in timo
and she was tiny like these ones and
interesting how far the disdain is
compared to a in teamer was kept as a
little one she was kept on the northern
side of she men this is right on the
southern side so it's the opposite ends
of Juma that ribbon is using and that's
only because probably the rest of the
clan has been down in this area much
safer for her in kind of moving around
in in other parts of Juma the moment
where she people be on the fringes and
obviously things like lions and and the
likes could be a danger to intriguing
that they've come this far south to to
din so test now you say hyenas are the
most adorable animals in the African
bush well Tesla I think Jamie has been
brainwashing you too much I'm taking it
they are I do like hyenas I must be
understand if you have there is a spot
for them and I love their sort of social
structures and mental intelligence that
they display but I'm not sure I would
call them cute when they old you know
there's there's many things that are
heinous but cutest maybe not it when
they grow up as little Cubs yes I'll
give you that but as an adults
I'm not so sure and we look at the likes
of some of these really old old females
when they teeth go kind of like little
pebbles and they've got scars everywhere
and they really don't look very inviting
at all sit and look like almost like
something out of a nightmare but when
they're young like this and they stay
tiny
then they are super super cute Algy I'll
agree with that that's for sure but
still not as cute as a little leopard or
lion cub in my opinion more little baby
any baby rhino there's a super cute
animals baby hippo baby giraffe anything
baby really is cute but I'm not sure
hyenas will rank above some of those but
I'm glad that you like them it's always
nice that there's a lot of people that
appreciate hyenas and I think that's one
thing that's been really nice about
working at safari live is the ability to
see how people's perceptions have
changed due to spending time with an
animal in educating and we were talking
earlier about insects and the likes
I think hyenas have gotten a much better
name thanks to the likes of Jamie and
and various other members of the team
that do spend lots and lots of time with
these hyenas and try and kind of get
people to really enjoy them good I think
we're gonna leave Riven she's kind of
tucked in there they can't really see
anything so we're gonna leave her to
herself in the little ones and the
meantime though let's send you back up
to David
well Tristana
stay with us Highness there and you
never know what might happen maybe
before we end the show I've stuck on the
same distance quite a distance from this
particular female cheetah whom we called
Basara and all the time I've been here
I've been hearing lions which will
normally happen at night in general and
it tends to be more males that will be
more vocal tonight than the females of
course trying to re-establish their
territories and telling would be other
mayors that may want to sneak in this
particular territory do not take any
chances
I'm guessing those bars could be the key
to males or the cheetah is Fredd at the
same spot who has he laid down in the
center of your screen and you can see
her eyes every time she turns looking at
us and then Thompson's gazelle I in the
same spot the one
I'll not be surprised if maybe come here
tomorrow morning and find how is a kill
from this night oh she will slowly and
surely get close to those tummies and
early in the morning before it gets hot
decides to execute aunt and gets herself
some breakfast who knows but alia when
we saw her walking
she looked being in worship her belly
looked fine and we saw her in her
drinking some water which is very
typical when you know these cuts have
lots of proteins in their tummies so an
indication that she was doing fairly
well so I haven't seen any other sign in
half that would tell me you know she
really wants to hunt but she's putting
those three for Tommy's and then she
like remained where she is well ladies
and gentlemen this has been a wonderful
day for us in the Mara giraffes
elephants Buffalo's lions and now a
cheetah and I think and we have moments
you okay we might be saying
goodbye just in case maybe marry the
director comes to us on a cross cuts but
if he does not thank you for being with
us in from the mara is goodbye
it's a little listen do I once I've
composed myself I'll share right
just a little listen here at the
porthole well you know they director
links from the presenter but they're
linking from there try and repeat his
link sometimes presenter can really toss
the director under the bus by giving a
very long and involved and complicated
link and that's just what happened there
as it was just rather amusing
ah what a beautiful day what is having
him drink there's something drinking oh
I think it's very neatly the birds we
started on no doubt of it
there we are look at that so Egyptian
geese how wonderful how he started is
how we shall end
so we're just going to have a little
listen to the sounds of the coming night
which at this stage consists largely of
crickets
I'm not pretty
I suspect that two of those Egypt induce
are the offspring of the other two
unlikely Egyptian geese at levels of
gotohome
which remained childless as is their
peculiar won't
no frogs anymore and a per season frogs
because of the lack of rain truth must
feel like we've had a lot of rain but
really I don't think we have much or
what the total is
would you say that these are beautiful
ducks yes well although they are called
Egyptian geese there are in fact ducks
and why they are called the geese is a
little bit of a mystery there are lots
of different sort of guesses as to why
they should be called East but in fact
they are ducks geese are supposed to
have a spur on their wings like the spur
winged news which I have seen one here
it flew around before took them once and
then decided it didn't like the look at
that at all and it flew off somewhere
else huge bird
and ronger calling its lost in the
riverbed below along with some spotted
d-cups all right everybody that's going
to be it for this Sunday sunset Safari
will of course see you tomorrow at 0
5:30 in the morning on Monday many of
you will be driving in the traffic I
will be driving around in this
magnificent wilderness thank you for
your questions and comments stay safe
and happy wherever you happen to be on
planet earth
[Music]